[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo what is up everybody welcome back to
another
exciting saturday morning 3d live stream
now if you guys can hear me hopefully
i'm seeing the levels you know last time
i started hot out the gates without any
levels we ain't gonna do it this time
all right
we're starting this thing right um this
is a very very exciting stream
we got a lot of familiar faces in the
chat what's up guys thanks for making it
back
um so let's just get right into it uh
this is a special stream because it is
yet another duo stream it's a partner
stream
and it is with the one and only mr
steve begin how are you doing dude
what's going on
i'm doing great thanks man so glad i got
to be here today
yeah man i'm so excited yes we're gonna
do something amazing we're gonna do
something really cool today and that is
um well before before we get into what
we're going to do
um let's uh let's introduce steve real
quick so
steve um he's been in his spare time
he has graciously donated his spare time
to to help
teach me unreal engine um and he is a
lead creative technologist
at dimensional innovations um he's doing
unreal work
all the time like that's his full-time
job as unreal you also you do
educational training videos with epic is
that right
yep uh they have an online platform with
a bunch of free tutorials i do a bunch
of stuff for like architecture and
visualization
lots of cool stuff yeah man um dude just
over the last like
man i feel like it's been three months
you've you've really been
donating your free time and like helping
me learn unreal and it's been
you've changed the game for me man like
i i am nothing but but gracious for
everything that you've taught me
and i'm excited for you guys because
we're gonna we're gonna create something
really cool together
um so we're trying to figure out like
what are we gonna do what are we gonna
do so
we decided that we want to create a
real-time
cinematic landscape and we're basically
going to go back and forth
and like you know tackle different parts
of this
so we're going to start out steve you're
going to be in unreal
shaping the landscape is that right yep
that is right
sweet so you can talk to these guys
about like the sculpting brush and all
that stuff and i think that's what it's
called
i'm not sure um you know how to sculpt
terrain and whatnot so
get you guys set up on that we're also
going to go over like a temp lighting
setup with maybe some
fog and and some sunlight to make it
look nice
um while steve is doing that i'ma be in
cinema 4d
sourcing some assets like some radar
dishes some towers and
all that stuff that i will eventually
bring into
unreal engine i'm going to send those to
steve so he can place them into his
scene
from there steve's going to use the
foliage brush
is that what it's called foliage yeah
foliage brush polish tool yeah and he's
gonna get it at all get it all nice and
get a bunch of like trees and stuff up
in there
um some plants and bushes well i'm gonna
work on texturing and unreal
right so i've been working on this in
tandem switching back and forth so you
guys can be learning a whole bunch
and then from that point we're gonna
combine forces i'm going to send all my
stuff over to steve
he's going to put it into his scene and
we're going to basically art direct it
together we're going to light it you
know tweak the lighting
we're going to work on camera settings
we're going to work on our volumetric
height fog and all that good stuff and
make it look really nice
um from there we're gonna render out
basically a uh high-res image
and i'm gonna take it into photoshop and
i'm gonna do some photoshop magic
make it look super nice probably add
some cinematic bars to it you know
uh and it's gonna look awesome we're
gonna have a sweet really cool looking
piece
at the end of this thing so i'm amped
steve are you uh
feeling good does that sound about right
to you i'm excited to see what this is
gonna look like
when it's done that's that's one of the
best parts for me like i know like all
the steps to get there and like the way
we're going to add lighting and foliage
and landscape and all that
but like i have an idea what it's going
to look like but just kind of like
getting there and then once we're in
those final steps where we're doing like
the art direction and iterating
that's the fun part for me absolutely
yeah that's when you get to like really
mess with the lighting and stuff and
like all the technical work is kind of
finished it's just the creative side
um but we're gonna get there we're going
to get there before we jump in guys
um got to give a big shout out to
skillshare
um for making this stream possible for
making all these streams possible so i'm
going to throw it
to skillshare for you guys real quick
and then we're going to hop right into
it and we're going to take a look at our
references
and make something cool together i'll
see you guys in like two minutes
stream is brought to you by our friends
over at skillshare skillshare is an
online learning community for creatives
like you guys who are looking to up
their game
grow their value and learn a new skill
now it doesn't matter if you're a
beginner
intermediate or advanced on your journey
you can learn
anything here on skillshare at any level
so since we're using unreal engine 4
on today's stream i want to show you
guys three tutorials that i think you
guys would actually really love here
now the first is an absolute beginner's
guide to learning unreal engine 4 by
michael rix and he walks you through
all of the the stuff you got to get into
the entire process
on on all things unreal engine now it's
super cool because these things are
bite-sized they come in little chunks
here so that you can fit them into your
schedule
next up here we have a virtual
filmmaking intro
in unreal engine it's a 30 minute course
and this gives you an overview of
what the virtual filmmaking process is
like
in unreal engine it's the cool idea that
you can use your real camera
to shoot actual footage here inside of
unreal engine
from here you guys can you know look up
other courses on skillshare that dive
deeper
into the virtual filmmaking process and
finally for anyone who's
really looking to dive in to landscapes
there's this unreal engine 4 open world
landscape course by greg wandra it's
15 hours nearly 16 hours and it just
breaks down
everything you guys need to know when
trying to make
a a stylized or photo real open world
landscape for a game that you're trying
to create
unreal engine 4 is a free program so it
just takes the
time to learn it in order to harness its
full capabilities
so as a skillshare member you guys get
unlimited access to regularly updated
premium content
for less than 9.99 a month for a yearly
subscription and to the first thousand
people who clicked the link in the
description
i got you guys with a free trial of a
skillshare
premium membership you guys are gonna
learn something new
you're gonna grow you're gonna get past
the competition and it also helps me out
too it helps me do more of these live
streams so click the link in the
description
and start learning
all right y'all it's uh it is time
but yeah big big shout outs to
skillshare man those guys are great
it really helps me out click that link
down in the description you guys are
going to learn something
and it'll help me do these streams as
consistently as possible
so i really appreciate y'all um and mr
hans is up in here
for again super chat and like crazy my
goodness man i appreciate you
um hang in there it's gonna be a long
stream
it's gonna be a good one um steve is
actually standing
um so he's going uh advanced mode on
this one i'm
i'm feeling brave i'm gonna try to go
the whole time standing also my cat took
my chair so i don't really have much
option here
um cool so
we have some references here what are we
looking at steve
yeah so we were looking at the
i hope i'm pronouncing this correctly
the arecibo observatory
uh this used to be the
largest satellite in the world uh after
hurricane maria
uh it had some damage and it collapsed
and it's been decommissioned since then
uh so i pulled up some reference images
of this bad lad
and pure ref gotta love prf it's so nice
it's the best
um yeah so i'm i'm gonna try to emulate
kind of this uh exterior landscape the
foliage
um i couldn't really get a good uh image
of like
what the trees look like close up i
guess this is a pretty good image but
it's just like a giant
mass of green and uh some nice
dirt and there we're gonna try to like
get pretty close to this sort of like
grungy material uh if we can
figure out what that looks like yeah
that's my challenge i also found some
yeah that'll be a fun one
uh this observatory was also a location
in the goldeneye film
and consequently the goldeneye game
and remake obviously uh
so um yeah i think we can
i think we can match that
and then i was also yeah i was also
looking at some locations from star wars
uh i love the the way like the moss
and the the dirt and the grime and
everything kind of like
meshes with the geometry this is really
cool inspiration art
i was hoping this would be you know
sunken into the ground and we could use
that as a reference but this is also
pretty cool as well
i love the clouds here and the the depth
um yes so that's that's what i'm going
off of
uh i'm thinking the landscape
uh i was looking at some images of
puerto rico and
where this is it's mostly flat with a
lot of like hills and
volcanic rock uh like cliffs hanging out
like we can see
along the edge and under these towers so
i'm thinking
mega scans for some cliff geometry um
trees i'll probably just pull
something that's uh pretty generic
greenish we can modify it later for sure
yeah and then as far as the satellite
and like the infrastructure
i'll be sourcing stuff that i got from
cgtrader.com
um they have some like really cool packs
with a bunch of stuff that i'll be
showing you guys
and i'll just be sourcing that stuff
while steve is kind of shaping this
landscape
we'll probably start on steve because
like shaping the landscape with the
landscape tool is more
of a thing than just me pulling models i
can show you that briefly once we get to
a point
um but before we jump in shout outs to
you guys
with the super chats aztec thank you so
much sir um
it will be a good stream i know it and
uh and
zato zatuichibit says uh check out
nvidia omniverse it's good for working
collaboratively collaboratively on the
same scene in unreal engine photoshop
and other software but you need an rtx
graphics card have you heard of this
steve have you heard uh i've omniverse
i've heard of it i haven't
explored it yet um it sounds
really awesome uh i just haven't had a
reason to use it quite yet
yeah i've never heard of it but
definitely i'm gonna look into that for
sure
yeah um okay so
yeah if i guess if you just wanna start
with the you know shaping up the
landscape and walk them through that
i'll just be sourcing some some radar
dishes and stuff
yeah absolutely so to get started and to
save us some time i uh pulled a couple
asset packs i already had
so this tropical jungle is going to have
a lot of foliage and this spring
landscape has a really
versatile master material this is going
to be
really awesome for us to use obviously
we don't want snow
but just like this procedural landscape
with the the grass and the rock
on the slopes that's gonna be really
cool and that's gonna save us a lot of
time
also um compiling shaders i got that out
of the way and for landscapes that can
take a really long time so i got that
and then i also imported this tropical
jungle
that has some really cool trees a lot of
nice like
ferns and ground cover i don't think
we're gonna
need anything like small on the ground
because we'll probably
be like having cameras like really high
above the ground but yeah
good to have that as an option uh i like
all the vines in here that'll be really
cool that's beautiful
yeah yeah a lot lots of
awesome assets in here i think i got
these as um
free monthly asset packs a couple of
months ago
so you show me that's super generous
yeah for sure so if you go
into the epic games launcher and go up
to marketplace
and then you go to this free section you
you see a bunch of like free epic games
content like what they had for paragon
all that is open and accessible some
mega scans
free for the month is what you got to
check out um
they have an animal theme this month
evidently so you can get like a nice
rigged dog
some low poly cats there's always like
some really awesome environments though
and
this modular house really nice as well
so lots of free stuff always free is
always nice yeah
so i went ahead and imported both of
those packs
and uh added this very very basic
landscape
with that material took me hours to
compile everything there so
let's just dive right in uh if we go to
lit view up here
it's black uh in my outliner you can see
i just have the landscape there's no
volumetrics
no lighting anything like that let's uh
sculpt this a little bit go up to modes
and landscape and then we can just
paint on here raising the lower as we
want to
so the middle where we put the dish
that's going to have to be
like a bit of a bowl sort of shape
so let's do something like this that's
not gonna be nearly big enough
and just punch that down a little bit
what's your scene scale how do you know
your scene scale
that's good question if i zoom way in
here we can see
like that's that's how small and
detailed it gets let's um
be smart i'll go to the select tool and
add a
mannequin that we can use
for scale there's a person
six foot tall robot
awesome well there's a there was a
really cool tip that you told me that we
didn't get hooked up because we were
dealing with other stuff
at the at the time but you can hit like
zero or numpad one like what do you hit
and it like spawn something
um like it'll spawn like the chrome ball
with like the the color the color change
yeah yeah uh
oh man i need to remember this
there's a hotkey where you can yep okay
so it's
backslash if you push and hold backslash
it finds whatever
you're hovering over and it places a
preview mesh there in this case it's
just a mirror ball that shows
color values but we can also let's go in
here and do this now we can replace that
mesh
with the mannequin so we can just push a
button and see what it's like for scale
this is called preview mesh
yep preview meshes i'm just going to add
another one here
search for my good old manny
put him in there close that out
and then if i hold shift and hit yeah
backslash we get
next one that's great that'll be helpful
yeah yeah
all right let's hop back into the
landscape
that dude is just itty bitty
where is he there he is all right
yeah cause i'm gonna have to basically
like in cinema
guesstimate your scene scale place these
radar dishes and towers
kind of as close as i can get them send
you my c4d file which you'll use the
data smith
importer to open up and then you'll have
all my radar dishes and stuff in your
scene and then you'll you'll fine tune
the adjustment on
on all those and whatnot right so
i'll try to keep it like pretty pretty
flat
so it's not too hilly and i can adjust
that later it's cool i'm still sourcing
these
these uh models here and then once we
get to a point we'll
we'll make it work
how long have you been in uh unreal
engine how long you been using it
oh gosh um for about
five years give or take before that i
was spending all my time in after
effects
um motion design animation so it's a
pretty easy transition for me for sure
i grew up on andrew kramer and uh
grayscale gorilla that was my jam for
the longest time
man those guys are still great like i
know
the grey school game they never stopped
yeah
so good um
yeah we actually we did a stream uh
they sponsored one of my streams like
the one right before christmas it was
the one on like uh
what was it like uh product photography
product lighting and stuff nice yeah it
was a fun one
that was grayscale yeah they they uh
they sponsored that one and like yeah
their whole they're like their whole
grayscale gorilla hub stuff in c4d is
the best right now it's so sick
all right i could i could tweak this all
day
i'll um
[Music]
let's see i'll add a little bit of
erosion around here
you can kind of see like this procedural
landscape material
adds like rocky cliffs where there's a
steeper incline which is really cool
once we had some lighting
actually i'm going to do that now yeah
cause i can't really see anything
all right i'll go back to the select
tool let me go to
lit mode and again right now we just
have
landscape and our mannequin i'm going to
start by adding a
directional light this is going to
simulate the sun
boom just add that right in there
and then we're going to add a skylight
this is going to emulate
a sky believe it or not let's set both
of those to movable
this was always confusing to me because
like there's so many different
lighting options you know in cinema it's
just a sun
and an environment and
maybe some hog but like in unreal
there's maybe like
10 different ones and it looks so cool
already yeah yeah so we just added
exponential height fog and
immediately we can see how like the sun
goes through the fog and we get a little
bit of atmosphere in here
we're also going to add a sky atmosphere
um
atmospheric fog is i believe deprecated
now as of like 4 25 26 what does that
mean sky atmosphere
that means um there are better options
to get what you're looking for
okay so uh
i will yeah make sure that's all good
directional light
there's an option in here we gotta
enable
uh atmosphere sunlight so then it's
actually
referencing and using that sky
atmosphere correctly
and this is really cool i'm going to
make sure rotation is not snapped
if i rotate the sun object we get
realistic atmosphere that is so sick
like it is so fast too that's what i
love about it it's insane
it's insane let's make it even more
crazy though
just to show how power and powerful and
versatile this is
and to save all before i get too crazy
i'm going to change my camera speed bam
crank that up crank this up and i'm just
going to
blast off to outer space here we go
we're going we're going we're going i'm
going to look down
keep going keep going because we're
using the sky atmosphere
dude it's like 2000 we actually get yeah
this is where you uh you cut in some
dramatic music
i'm assuming um but we actually get
planetary fog and as i rotate the camera
you can even see like the fall off and
the color fringing
it's just unbelievable and i'm going to
see if i can oh we got windbush up in
here dude what's up winbush good to see
you man hey buddy
that's great we got caves and wind bush
up in here that's
amazing
as we rotate the sun you can see exactly
what it would look like
as it falls off that's crazy to an
atmosphere that's so cool
it's unbelievable it is just so sweet
okay i'm gonna hop back down to the
earth
uh change your camera
it's so hard to work on like at the same
time because i'm just listening to what
you're
doing what you're saying and i'm like
wait i was just watching the tutorial
like i gotta get back
my side of things all right and
just a couple more things we're going to
do here to make
the the fog actually uh simulate a
sunset better
we actually need to go into the
exponential height fog
and change fog and scattering color to
black
as well as the directional in scattering
because those two values are additive
so we don't want to get incorrect color
values especially when we're talking
about
color and lighting this early in the
game
guaranteed i'm watching this tutorial
back guaranteed
[Laughter]
welcome back clint hope you enjoy this
fun tutorial
uh okay so i'm gonna do that and then
let's also add
some depth to that fog
instead of point zero two
point one it's underwater underwater
scene right there
maybe i won't
point one okay okay
0.02 let's let's add second fog maybe we
can like
get like a nice fine layer of fog
closer to the ground that'd be pretty
cool
man did you ever play death training i
have
not it's on my list someday when i have
time
so are you getting vibes yeah i mean
from this and like
these uh there's there's a place or
there's a level in death training where
it's like a giant radar dish
and all these radar pieces that i'm
messing with like feel very similar
um nice i'm gonna switch over to me real
quick um
okay dang i have our heads
optimized for uh or unreal
so you guys have to bear with bear with
that when i'm in c4d
but yeah check this out like i'm doing
this like uh
these massive radar dishes and stuff
that will drop into the scene it looks
like the eiffel tower
that's intense um so we'll we'll
probably use some of these here again
these are from cgtrader.com they're
probably my favorite
favorite site for that stuff you got the
smaller ones and then
there's an antenna pack too this will
probably be the main
guy um that i'll be using here for
for the big radar dish and then like
that
yeah i love those details on the back
yeah yeah it's good stuff
and then i'll probably use some of these
guys here for
the perimeter there's all these things
around the perimeter
these tiny ones probably don't need to
mess with but maybe we can intersperse
them around
as needed but
yeah i'll place these kind of based off
of
some of that reference that we were
looking at earlier
but uh yeah that's all i want to show
you guys for now back to uh
back to steve here
so a lot of people are saying this
environment is also in
battlefield four uh i i i actually
got really into battlefield three but i
never got into four
but i'm sure we could pull some good
reference from there as well
uh one more awesome thing we can add
here
going to place actors i'm going to
search for volumetric cloud
and boom we get some clouds that's so
sick and they move and stuff too right
yep it's just it's there it's going it's
doing its thing so crazy
uh there's some color fringing i i might
want to like adjust later but
uh we'll see if that's even in our final
shot
but man that looks good we can actually
go into our directional light too
and uh set this to
cast clouds uh shadows through clouds
maybe i can uh get a cool image here
oh i love it oh that's so sweet
i can't wait i can't wait once it's all
together and like
we got our giant radar dish with our
foliage and
our towers like it's going to be so much
fun to tweak the lighting on
this fog's a little bit too dense for me
let's try 0.01 fog density 0.02
yeah yeah that's good
our exposure is way too low
do that for now i always uh just
dial in the exposure in the viewport and
then worry about it later when we have
actual cameras in the scene so
for sure we'll come back to that yeah
we'll get there towards the end
all right man i want to play battlefield
4 now
i know like pubg or so then
yeah this is um looking pretty good
let's talk about uh some plug-ins and
project settings
so yes please i always uh yeah i always
just um
go in here and disable uh autosave
because i like to live life on the edge
i don't need any of that i go into
project settings
this is a raytracing project so i have
that enabled
if you do that you also want to set your
default rhi to directx 12.
i don't believe ray tracing is currently
supported on macs
maybe you have to have like some wacky
hardware or something i'm not really
sure
um but it's working for us so that's
good
i also went ahead and uh generated
mesh distance fields we were talking
about this before client but quick
refresher for everybody what this does
is uh it's used as a form of
lighting and also helps with some
material stuff that we might get into
later
and it uh mesh distance fields it's sort
of referencing like a depth pass
and it takes everything in the scene and
uh generates almost like an
ambient occlusion map but like inverted
sort of so we can use just like a really
quick
depth uh
pass essentially to light stuff
to deal with foliage things like that
because i'm not gonna i'm not gonna bake
any lighting there's gonna be way too
many objects here
that's gonna be crazy i also disabled a
bunch of
um shader permutations um because i'm
not doing this for mobile i don't
want to waste time any valuable computer
juice on that
and uh one more thing i enabled if you
go into
editor preferences and search for
procedural
there's a feature called procedural
foliage that is
not used very often in my experience
but it's extremely powerful so i want to
try using that
for this project so we can try to like
place
like seeds essentially for where trees
would be and then how many generations
of trees there would be how big they
would grow how much shade they need
all that awesome stuff so i'm just gonna
like do a quick test with that
that's insane yeah
uh we're gonna add a procedural full
foliage
volume i'm gonna skill this bad boy
two thousand two thousand it's way too
small
fifteen thousand
oh
there we go and uh
we need some trees in here
let's see so here's my tropical jungle
pack
i got some meshes where where's the dish
gonna be
trees dish is gonna be
uh actually right where this is right
now i'll move that out of the way so i
can test this somewhere else
but yeah this got a nice yeah
collision foliage spawner here we go
procedural foliage spawner that's what
we want
let's make a new folder call this
procedural foliage because i'm creative
call this here
spawner the naming system is important
though too
because there's you get a lot of stuff
going in your scene and if it's
confusing then
you're gonna you're gonna lose sight of
side of everything basically right it
gets confusing totally
and uh if you're ever sharing projects
with other team members
uh you better have a good naming
convention and everyone's on that same
naming convention
um fortunately the people i work with uh
when we're on the same project we are on
it and everyone is like very
good about naming stuff but if i went
with like tree
one final final underscore one
yeah that's rough final for real this
time
ultimate fun yeah let's see
okay we need to what do we do here
levi man there's a way to
make this into procedural
i'll come back to that dude i'm looking
at this uh
at this reference i'm gonna switch over
here to me real quick i'm looking at
this reference
and there's these little roads leading
up to
the different towers and there's all
these like ropes
and wires stretching across from all
these towers and i'm trying to figure
out like
what's the best way to do those splines
and those rope splines and stuff
um i probably want to do all that in c4d
right do all the modeling in c4d
and then kick it out to you i could use
like topo toppo wire or something or
maybe i could just simply do some some
easy splines
from point to point but
as far as the roads go there's roads
leading up to these towers
and that might have to just not be
included
[Laughter]
we could uh we could probably come back
to that
later on yeah if we have time yeah if
it's
if it's worth it i think regardless
it'll just be really sick it'll be
really cool
um all right i'm going back going back
to you here
all right procedural foliage here we go
i had to make a procedural foliage
mesh type i'm going to try using this
mesh yep medium one okay so i get all
these options
i want minimum and maximum offset i like
to
dip the maximum maybe like 50
centimeters
uh yeah minimum and then max zero so
like
if the tree starts underground a little
bit that'll add a little bit more
variation align to normal yep let's do
that slope angle cool cool
all right here's the fun stuff we can
determine how much they grow whether
they grow in shade
i believe they would uh
how many steps for clustering seed
density man there's so much stuff
and this is like how how trees
scale in size over age like it's
unbelievable i even get that option here
wow
um mobility static that's fine we can
cast a shadow
yeah we'll see how that goes um
collision not worried about that
dude have you heard of this cable actor
in unreal um yeah
yeah um this is pretty sweet it's like
dynamic i've used it once before for uh
uh
just like cables in a room that like
attached to a wall
i couldn't get collisions to work well
enough
that it wasn't uh just wacky
and just bouncing around all over the
place do you want to try it
definitely i think we can do it once i
get my stuff
in to the scene um
we can probably do those once on you
we'll probably have to do them on your
end
cause like i'm messing with them here
and like it looks really cool
it you know pretty much just like
dynamic cables that you can up the
segments on
like 20 segments like that's pretty
sweet
um yeah and like once we get the the
radar dishes and the antennas like
specifically placed then we'll come in
and probably add these after the fact
and we can do it on your side
since the final will be on your end
yeah yeah okay well i won't worry about
cables then thank you whoever said that
was it thiago maybe um there's a couple
of you guys
giving me some tips here in the chat
which i always appreciate so
shout outs to y'all we'll use that once
we uh get a little further on in the
process
all right steve i'm on you back to you
all right
so uh i grabbed a couple i got these
medium trees
i think these uh let's get one with
vines as well
oh come on there we go yep yep yep
and maybe this large one that'd be cool
for some variation
uh okay where did i procedural foliage
duplicate that one open that here we go
find that and
[Music]
that's the last one i did topic one
let's do tropic three
boom all right so we're compiling
shaders i'll see how that goes in the
meantime
go back to my procedural foliage spawner
and then i want
four options because i have four
different kinds of trees and
let's just
drag them in here
here's the first one and two
and three and four easy
unique tiles random seed tile size
see let's see how this goes um
spawn fingers crossed we don't crash
i believe we want to yep okay
all right not bad not bad
we got we got a uh
we got a forest wow
that is that's something crazy
that is dense is oh boy
all right uh let's make some changes i
believe
this actually uses the foliage tool so
we could even go in here
and nope maybe not i was hoping we could
just like
paint out some of these um
[Music]
no luck all right uh let's
hmm can you paint the area
that the procedural foliage
will spawn in
there might be a way to do that
that's a good question uh i know we can
have this
cube and then we can have like a
blocking volume which i was going to do
for
where the dish itself is so i'll just
like
block out this little crater
and have trees all the way around it
alternatively i could just go into the
foliage tool up here i have all these
trees selected
let's dump the density down to like 0.1
and we can just paint that looks good
that's like
that's fine that's probably the easier
way to go about it but
i guess i just want to be difficult
learn something new here
show everybody how to use procedural we
get some fun shadows here i'll have to
take care of as well
all right let's uh see what we can do
with this one
yes okay so if we go in here we can
change the
number of steps let's just do let's do
two
yep yep
clustering two boom boom probably should
have done this with one and then
duplicated
but uh here we are
collision radius okay so this is
100 centimeters per tree is what it's
saying and it's saying
when this tree grows old and it drops
seeds in the ground
those have to be more than 100
centimeters away for that tree to
actually grow
and then shade is kind of the same thing
like if the tree can't grow in shade
here's how much shade
that's actually going to cast i'm saying
all these trees can grow in shade
um or spawn in shade interesting okay so
let's try bumping this up to 250 for
each
we'll do 150 here just something nice
and arbitrary
how's it going on your end there clint i
mean i basically have my stuff ready to
send
um i'm gonna switch over here so
we're basically just looking at this
like big setup here um
i know you can't really see my screen
you're kind of watching the stream to
see what i'm doing
but i have the big radar in the middle
and i have three of the biggest
towers um like equidistant in a triangle
around this thing in the center i have
this little center antenna piece
included for you
but we may want to lose it so it's
separate
and this is kind of the base of our
scene and i'll throw in all of these
guys too if we want to
you know mess with some other ones here
too but
i think what we have here is a good you
know good setup
that i can send to you and you can drop
this in the scene
and i can start working on texturing um
it's gonna take me a minute to texture
this stuff and make it look really nice
i really do want to go for that like
super high detailed um let me see if i
can get
uh this for you guys yeah like this
super grungy tiled look
i i don't know if i if i can get that
but i'll do my best i will do my best
boss don't worry you're not late
just on time thanks for joining y'all we
got 631 people up in here
um it's a good time for those of you
guys who
just joined i'm here with uh steve begin
he is a an unreal master he's a teacher
in his spare time he's been taken he's
been teaching me how to do this stuff so
we decided let's do a stream together
make something cool um
so yeah i'm gonna send him over
basically the radar dish that i
that i had set up in c4d he'll drop that
into his unreal scene and then i'm
hopping
unreal and start texturing and we're
just basically
tackling different little pieces of this
of this overall scene
together and then we're going to combine
forces at the end to get the final look
with the lighting and the fog and all
that stuff and then
i'll bring it into photoshop to really
make it look nice and tweak the colors
and
the values and whatnot so right now
we're just at the point where steve is
blocking out the landscape he's adding
foliage right now
and i am essentially about to send him
the radar dish and
the towers we'll do the splines and
everything
using the cable actor in unreal as well
so
steve how does
the data smith importer work do i just
send you my c4d file and you
bring whatever i have in my c40 file
into your unreal scene
yeah so if you export uh c4d
uh actually just save it as we should be
able to import
via the data smith plugin and we'll get
all of your geometry with their correct
pivots materials textures
lights animations everything okay uh
so let's give that a go sweet let me i
don't know why there's materials i'm
gonna delete all these materials
um yeah so i'm just save this thing let
me get rid of
all this stuff here make this as easy as
possible for you
and it maintains the position of all
this stuff too right
right yep i guess that's the whole point
of doing this right is
position will actually stick um but our
scene is not too complicated
i'm gonna do alt g to group stuff um
this null is called uh
i don't know radar parts
and then i'll just have another one
called main scene
and i'll save as infrastructure
underscore for steve
amazing um
and let's see i'm gonna go to i'm gonna
switch to your display
and we're about to see whether this
works
yeah okay all right i just i added a uh
blocking volume for the procedural
meshes here i
dumped down the amount of foliage we're
going to have i also disabled the
shadows just for now
we can come back to that later and i
scaled this way way up about to
re-simulate
save everything fingers crossed
all right all right that works that's
super cool
yeah so this will be that and then i can
just like paint in the gaps
uh and if we even look at like these
trees
we can see kind of what they're doing
maybe
um maybe not
well they're lining to the hillside
correctly and
the landscape itself is actually
spawning grass
little rocks everywhere uh that's
man we could do like a whole jungle
scene looking down in like a canyon here
too
man there's so many options i love the
the sense of scale we get as well
yeah so cool the geometry that's gonna
be awesome you can shape the geometry
of the scene and still have the trees
stick is that right
yeah check this out so if we go to the
landscape tool
and i'm gonna mess with just a smaller
area
i could
i could sculpt there we go and then the
trees just pop right up
that's great super easy
got some good variation in here i might
want to go into the material
for this and add some randomness to the
color values
uh that'll help you i don't like how
it's like the same green
oh yeah and like right here if you
showed me this picture and said hey this
is
that ridge is a hundred meters away and
it's just grass
i'd believe it but that's not the case
so we gotta we gotta
fix that make something look hello so i
emailed you
my scene i'll switch over to my screen
here so no one catches your email
um let me see let me just open unreal
and see if i can't mess with this cable
thing i'm gonna switch over to me
and you're good to go ahead and hop into
your email and uh
pull that scene all right
let's see so how do i get one i want
like
oh that's the end location oh yes
perfect amazing so i guess you just
double click it
can i stretch it way out does it snap i
stretch it
too far it doesn't snap
that's awesome
and i guess you can adjust the cable
length to
like a thousand two thousand
three thousand that's so sick
it's all dynamic and everything i love
it
so if you move where the pivot is right
now it automatically updates
oh it won't jiggle is it
that's it i'm just asking oh yeah i know
it auto updates yeah
i guess it'll like it'll still have to
sag and bounce and everything i wonder
if there's a way i can settle it or
something
attached to start attach to end
oh wow that's so cool so you can have
them like
hanging and stuff like that whoa
that's awesome you can attach a attach a
camera to the end of that thing
do little like rides and stuff theme
park
that's awesome i love it
let me know if uh if you got my file
yeah i'm just gonna test it real quick
here let me switch to you before we
jump to it uh first yeah let's go for it
i'll i'll test it first sounds good just
to be safe
because i crash anything cable gravity
scale
i said that to zero it just chills
whoa go here we go
that's so cool someone yeah some really
good
tips here in the chat uh upping segments
that definitely helps with the
resolution of that
uh and someone also said the trees i got
to make them stand up instead of like
angle
in like on the slope that's a good call
all these little things i i just
completely gloss over yeah the chat's
great man
these guys i've learned so much from the
chat they're great
good community of people here you all
are awesome well for sure
what's up brendan what's going on thanks
for joining
y'all look great thanks for hanging in
there with me we got nearly 700 people
up in the chat right now it's
pretty awesome um how are you doing
steve you want to
switch and see how it works so it worked
let me uh i'm going to delete everything
so i can redo it so everyone can see
because this part of the process is like
yeah for sure
pretty awesome pretty important as well
so if you guys so
the way we're doing this um taking c4d
files and bringing them in
having it work pretty seamlessly we're
using the data smith
uh unreal data smith importer it's this
little thing here if you don't see this
you can go to let's see if i get this
plugins i think yeah uh edit plugins and
just type in
data smith and make sure it's enabled
you want to check that you also want to
check is there anything else or is that
it just you check the data smith c40
importer
um yeah c4d importer um i believe
there's also like a
data smith uh content content yeah you'd
probably want yeah
yeah um this one's for fbx's it looks
like
so you just want to check those and
you'll probably have to restart
your uh your unreal engine and then that
will be there
and you can just boop search for your
c40 file are you ready to
show them how it works dude i am ready
all right that's like here we're on you
all right so here we go i uh ignore
these two test folders
i was testing uh so if we go up to
the data smith button that we now have
i'm going to navigate to my
ds infrastructure c4d1
you can see we have like a big old file
size that's what we'd like to see
if you if you export datasmith from
like 3ds max revit sketchup you're also
going to have
a folder here with the same name you got
to keep those two in the same location
or this isn't going to work
so i'm just going to open that i'm going
to put it in my ds folder and then
i tried to get creative with the color
background but it was a bad idea as you
can see
we can import geometry materials
textures lights cameras animations
i'm only really concerned about geometry
but i'm going to keep it as is
one of the really awesome things here is
that it can automatically generate uvs
with a nice size resolution uh
again we're not baking any lighting so
it doesn't really matter and there's not
too much geometry so
not too concerned so i'm going to go
ahead and import
says it was not saved for melange
if anybody knows what that means for uh
cinema i would love to know i'm not a
cinema guy i used to be
but i would be what you call a bad
cinema 4d artist
uh okay so it added everything into my
scene which is awesome
they are under the ground which is not
awesome fine
it's uh okay
so let's look at what we got uh if i
select
these objects we can see they have their
own pivot which is
super cool uh we're gonna use these this
is looking
honestly very star wars in the best kind
of way
uh and we we see um
we try to get kind of close before we
get too laggy
you can see it's kind of looking like
this flat gray but that is because
it is just the um
[Music]
the default grid is kind of wacky on
here and it's not uh the same for
everything else
uh i spend most of my 3d time in 3ds max
obviously when i'm not unreal the way
you would resolve this
in that program would be to add a
uv unwrap to all those objects and then
use a map scalar modifier
and this is really important if you want
all the materials to stretch correctly
and have like good seams and everything
make sure everything is scaled correctly
for the uvs i use 100 centimeters at the
scale
unrealistic centimeters as most of the
world does
so um we might want to adjust that later
but a nice thing is we can just
re-import the data smith file and
everything will just
pop into place as as we want yeah um
i'll probably have to unwrap some stuff
in c4d
and because the next thing i'm going to
do here is start texturing
the radar dish and the towers and stuff
hopefully i can get
something that looks good enough this
will be a good test
here and feel free to scale those as
much as you need to fit that space there
and i'll just scale it on my end
about the same amount okay okay
so here's the thing if anyone wants to
cue up some like
dramatic music right now now
now would be the time i'll do this in
slow motion
[Music]
oh buddy
you might have to skill steal that guy
push your
ground in maybe scale the well radar
dish on the wall so instead of doing
that
so the cinema 4d um data smith file
it gave me this really awesome hierarchy
which i'm assuming reflects what you had
set up in your file probably
so we get the parent with these sub
parents and the objects themselves
i should just move main scene itself and
that'll move everything and then if i
scale
this they'll all be in the same relative
location is there a way to adjust the
game that's what i want
like sorry i said let me move the gizmo
so that they're it's hitting the center
point of those
objects i could take
these and
just slide them over yeah
there's there might be a way if anyone
wants to shout that out in the chat
wait it just happened uh so yeah so
the main scene is right where they're
where the pivot is if i move
these oh so everything but the main
scene
yeah i'm just trying to like put it
roughly the same position
yeah yeah there we go
okay so this is a three-time scale just
for your reference
here and that seems to fit pretty well
what what are you thinking
yeah pretty good size yeah seems about
right you might have to push the ground
in more
so you get more of the depth from that
radar dish or based off your reference
you could scale the radar dish on the y
um you know just to thin it out a little
bit
um you can lose that giant thing too
like that middle piece
yeah you can hide it i'm
i'm actually just gonna throw that under
the ground for now
great um i'll just remember i can just
snap it back to zero and that'll be
right where we need it to be uh maybe we
can even like put it down here so it can
be like part of the standing structure
infrastructure just add a little bit
more detail i guess we'll see but i'll
just hide it for now for sure
um yeah one thing to keep in mind too if
you're using
mesh distance fields to light foliage in
your scene for something
uh this scale you always want your
geometry to
stay uniform scale so one one one two
two two three through three
if i were to scale this on just the z or
the y or something
uh it would not like correctly with mesh
distance fields
is my understanding maybe it's just like
worse optimization or something but
um i could just disable mesh distance
fields as well
we'll we'll see i could um
[Music]
go in here search distance and we can
effect distance field
lighting it doesn't look any different
i'll need to just adjust the lights and
the skylight to
catch in there a little bit better
let me uh
[Music]
tuck that landscape down
i'm gonna try and bring these same
models into my scene
in unreal and texture these things
um once i get things kind of loaded up
i'll switch over to my end
and then i guess you'll just be tweaking
and get the foliage all nice and
everything
while i do that i i presume
yeah yep that sounds good to me cool
all right let's see i'm gonna switch
over to my display here
and let's see if i can't do the same
thing steve did let's open this up
i'll put this into ds theta smith folder
sure all this stuff is good
yeah so steve and i like built out this
master material
yesterday the day before and i'm going
to be using that
which i'm probably have to drop into our
scene here and
i'll use that to texture out you know
this radar dish and all the towers and
stuff
so hopefully that goes smoothly we'll
we'll see
i'm definitely challenging myself here
wow so this thing is so far away my
camera's moving but you brought you guys
probably can't tell
i'll switch this camera speed up to like
seven
and zoom up to it because it's really
large
i probably don't need any of these guys
i'm just gonna
i'm probably just gonna go ahead and
select all these guys and delete them
all of these antennas radar parts so we
can just hide it might as well
think for this i don't like this thing
either we'll hide that
um
hmm
so how would i go about unwrapping the
like there's so much geometry on this
thing
like unwrapping this would just be
insane like wha
actually there's a way we can do it in
unreal
um it's not as precise
but we could always do it that way if
you don't want to try to do it in
cinema potentially let me
let me like mess with some stuff first
let me get the mass material going
and once i'm at that point and i'm
getting some obvious errors then we'll
we'll do some some uv stuff
someone asked in chat is unreal only
used for games
no no it is definitely not
i use it for non-game development all
the time
architecture visualization automotive um
all sorts of stuff all sorts of fun
things we're not making a game here
we're just making a
really awesome environment um yeah but
that's a great question i mean the
the thing that got me into unreal was
seeing the qixel rebirth
uh trailer that was amazing if you guys
hadn't seen that definitely check it out
um same for memories of australia if you
look up memories of australia those were
the two things
that made me like oh my god i have to
learn unreal because it's real time and
they've created this and it looks
photo realistic i'm i'm in it for the
movie making side of things i don't
really have any intention of creating
games
though maybe that you know might happen
at some point like a small little thing
but
for me it's it's all about the cinematic
photo real
uh real-time element to it so
yeah yeah a couple months ago uh
you were on a maybe it was a live stream
maybe it was a podcast or something and
you said something along the lines of
like
i saw these two videos in unreal with
mega scans and it looks awesome
but i have a really hard time finding
tutorials for this content
and i'm just watching this listen to
some like clint let me talk to you
i want to show you it's so much fun yeah
definitely like
it's very frustrating because it's the
same thing that happened to me way back
in the day when i was
when i was learning cinema 4d i started
in c4d
release 10 um which was 13 years ago i
guess
at this point um and
i i stuck with it for like two versions
for about two years
and i got to the point where like i was
the one making the tutorials
for c4d at the time there was barely
anyone else i was doing it on
cgtutts.com you could probably still
find my tutorials on cgtouts.com
and i just remember seeing all these 3ds
max tutorials
all the things that i wanted to learn
how to do was all in 3ds max
all the tutorials were for that and i
got bummed out i was like you know what
screw it i'm just going to switch
so i switched to 3ds max for like six
years i was in
uh 3ds and it was because
i didn't have the good tutorials that i
wanted in c4d
now looking back it would have been cool
to stick with it and like
maybe create something like grayscale
gorilla at the time or
like a video co-pilot but that just
wasn't on my mind i was a kid i didn't
know anything
um but now i kind of ran into the same
issue with unreal it was like
i'm having these issues i want to be
able to create this stuff that i'm
seeing i'm only seeing the great work
i'm not seeing the tutorials that get me
there
um so sticking with unreal
has been a challenge for me it's been
difficult
um and i went i went through like a
first phase basically i had a couple
people like helping me out
i learned the program and then i kind of
took a little break
didn't want to give on give up on it i
felt bad for saying i gave up on it no i
didn't give up on obviously
i didn't give up on it um but then steve
was like dude i got you and has been
helping me out you know for the last
like three months in his spare time so
it's been it's been amazing man i really
appreciate it
yeah it's been a lot of fun i uh i gotta
say there are a lot of really good
tutorials out now
and if anyone is interested in making
them that's
probably the quickest way that you'll
learn more about the program
uh if you're teaching content and trying
to be that person who
knows what they're talking about that
means you've got to research it and
you've got to find out like
all those little quirks and all those
bugs and all those different options
that people are going to
have to go through so it's been really
helpful for me as well
i'm trying to find if anyone knows
uh cascading ray traced shadows
in unreal there's an option for it
somewhere
and that'll help us get better shadows
on the dish
and the foliage if anyone wants to shout
that out
that'd be sweet
is there like a material that i can
throw on here to test the uvs or is it
just
without materials you can obviously see
the uvs
if you go to uh starter content
materials if you have that in there
there's some good ones starter content
material and then just try like
one of the bricks or cobblestones
those are good yeah okay
someone's asking my uh computer stats
i'm
on a real nice lappy tappy here
uh quadro rtx 4000 i believe
very nice and uh i7 cpu
um i believe it's 16
32 gigs of ram i should know this i
totally should
that's legit an rtx and a laptop that's
a quadro and a laptop yeah
it gets real real toasty real
real toasty lappy taffy here um
yeah and i usually have my laptop screen
here and then a 4k monitor
but pushing 4k uh with ray tracing
um i i have a hard time getting more
than like 5 to 10 frames per second so
uh i'm just running that 1080 and it
looks great
very happy with it all right so my uvs
are definitely butt
um i think i have to fix those before i
move forward uh but sid
appreciate the super chat thank you you
say hey i've had a few mimosas
very nice and just wanted to say thanks
for everything uh you do
you're the reason i started my career in
filmmaking i hope to work
with you someday man dude that's awesome
much appreciated thanks for the shout
out enjoy the mimosas
um if you ever want to try a bromosa
it's a blue moon in orange juice
uh which which is always a good time
dude
next time i'm out in la let's get some
bromos i'm down
down someone
shouted out cascade shadow maps those
are in the directional light this is
true
and i've been digging around in those
but i can't find anything specifically
related to real-time ray tracing
but thank you i do appreciate that and
enjoy those mimosas man
okay my uvs are garbage do you want to
what's the best what's the best way to
fix these uvs here um are we doing this
in unreal
yeah so if you'd like i could show how
to do it and
talk through it that'd be better yeah
and then i'll follow along on my end
all right switching to you
all right all right i'm gonna bump this
up a little bit just to get
some brighter lighting i usually like to
keep this like
3.14 lux but 20 will help us see this a
little better
i'm going to make this uh this old
clay brick material just so we can see
it
an open big dish and it is
in fact a very big dish
let's look down here and this is
all the same uh grid except a
very very different scale on the larger
portions
if we have the data smith
plugins enabled we get this mesh editing
section where we could actually go in
and we can
edit some of the geometry we can remove
faces flip faces
elements add material channels
it tends to be kind of buggy but it can
be very helpful if you bring in like a
sketchup model
so you can like flip some of those
faces and walls and everything uh so
that'd be
um one feature we can do with with the
data smith
stuff but we also get this generate uvs
and unwrap uvs
so if we look at the uv channels we do
have uv channels zero there's
something there uh it's fine if this
goes over the grid
uh as long as there are faces here
that's fine uv channel one is what we
would use for
light mapping looks like some
hot garbage no offense
uh we are going to unwrap ub so
uh well no we want
generate uvs generate okay um yep
and uh i work with some really awesome
3d artists who are way better at
uv unwrapping than i am um christina
simon and ben dalman specifically are
so good at getting me uvs that look
phenomenal so huge shout out to them
uh but i'm gonna do it the cheap and
easy way uh if i go
box cylindrical or planar i think
cylindrical
will probably be the best option for us
here let's see it yeah
gizmo i don't want to see
that down there oh oh whoa
i don't want that keep that rotation
where it is and we can
fit the cylinder to the object okay oh
you're progressing you're trying to fit
it
to the thing you yeah show gizmo
and then fit hit fit yeah then it
obviously doesn't look right so we gotta
adjust it
and if we just uh let's just apply
and see how this looks just by default
and as soon as that's done
we're not going to see a difference in
the grid because by default it's still
using uv channel 0 so
we could actually overwrite that as the
target channel
um or go into the material and change
the texture coordinate to reference
uh channel two instead i'm gonna
i'm gonna be dangerous here i'm not
going to apply to target channel 0 as
well
yes overwrite 0 okay
okay we have something
i see snow definitely a repeating grid
looks much better i wish i could get
this uh
yeah turn off that there we go so it's
uniform
and that's the first thing i'm looking
for next i want it to
actually give me a good size
for all of those squares in the pattern
uh
we can't even see any so i'm going to
try changing the scale to
25.4 25.4 why
25.4 um most of the time when i'm
working with
architecture files uh people work in
inches
when you go inches to centimeters it's
uh
one inch is 2.54 centimeters so i'm just
thinking well maybe like if it's just
like some arbitrary large number
maybe it's some um multiplication of
that
maybe 100 by a hundred
see how this looks i'm getting these
like little triangles
inside of all this stuff what is going
on like it looks like you're no
yours looks way better you tried 100 so
the
500 under 100 yep so the
bottom of the dish coincidentally the
side we don't care about
uh looks good looks great um
but this part uh it's
good but we're gonna get a lot of
stretching here you see like
if we had the brick material um showing
it would look fine probably like these
squares here where it's like a perfect
square but where it's like
stretchy rectangles that's um
what we in the business like to call bad
i'm gonna try box like box has always
been
my jam let's apply that let's see what
it looks like
dang dude why why is this so difficult
yeah i feel like tearing edges
spherical we can't do spherical can we
no uh what we could do
is change it in a 3d program i could
even kick this out to 3ds
and do a simple unwrap in there and
re-import that
as just like a separate piece of
geometry uh
we could also change our material to be
referencing world position instead of
a uv channel so maybe we could do that
for this one
um how would you do that i'll try that
and then so i can get going on materials
and then
that doesn't work then i'll i'll
probably just unwrap in c4d or something
yeah so um
let me uh finish up this
and save this uh uv and i can
dive into that one
okay uh do you want me to walk you
through it or do you want me to
show how to do it um both
all right
so um
are we on you or me right now we're on
you um
oh okay i can't tell with the lag in the
video
oh good all good so uh yeah sorry for
that everybody uh so if i go to
make a new material i'm going to call
this m
world space just for a quick test here
make this bigger get rid of the stats
don't need that
so typically the way we would set up a
texture or excuse me materials we'd take
textures put them in here like this we
have diffuse we have roughness
we have normal looks great we get errors
because we don't have textures in there
obviously
i'm just going to switch this so it's
just one
brick and
this uv by default this is referencing
the first uv channel for whatever this
material is applied to
so this is looking at that
big grid we had or the thing we just
made
all that stuff from the last five ten
minutes but instead of that
we can right click and choose position
and get this world position node here
this references the object
in xyz world space and
outputs that and we could use that to
inform like color
we could use that for variation we could
use it for
vertex offset roughness whatever we want
but what i want to use it for is
the uvs themselves so we want to drag
out from world position
and choose component mask
and we want rg because that's going to
correlate with x and y
and this is where things are going to
get a little funky
this is only going to work correctly on
x and y we could make this
and there's some extra nodes i'd have to
figure out how to do that again but we'd
layer in
the z channel as well but for now let's
just see how this looks if we plug that
into
let's plug this into a multiply yeah
and a scale parameter
just the general general scale yep
plug that into uvs and i'm compiling
shaders
let's give that a couple years to finish
but uh if you save this and make an
instance of it you can change uh scale
if you have it on your end
um yeah you can go ahead and take it
away alright yeah switch over still
saving my stuff
so this is just like this is just a test
right to see how it looks exactly okay
cool yep
um and if it looks good we can put that
in our master material
yeah let's see so instance it
yep create material instance this is
called world
space
and uh save control shift s
someone points out you'll need to find a
solution to make tripling for normal
maps that's a good point
um maybe at the distance we'll be
looking at this object
um because it's gonna be like back here
like we're probably gonna see it closest
it'll be like
like here but we obviously want to get
the towers in too so we want to find a
nice angle that like shows
everything maybe something like this or
something we might do an angle
you know like way up here or something
looking straight down as like
like a helicopter view like flyover
thing could be really cool
um so we're not going to be like super
up in here
but yeah so i have the material applied
but i don't see anything okay
let's uh open that instance and change
the scale to like
point zero one let's see how that looks
yeah there we go
yeah there we go yeah and you can see
uh how it works on those two planes but
wow yeah that's actually uh
not bad
that's not bad yeah i think the best way
though is to get them to be radial
you know so it's like spiraling in
towards the center i have no
idea how to do anything like that we
could try a rotation
thing but i don't think i think it's
just
the uvs they have to be like spiraling
down cylindrical
yeah if could could you make it radial
in
cinema the uvs
yeah i believe in you clint all right
let's go back to cinema um
all right let's let's see maybe maybe um
you want to keep working on foliage i'll
see if i can figure this out
yeah all right
um let's see i'm gonna walk them through
here my process on
on how to do the uvs or at least how i
have figured it out
my janky way of figuring it out all
right so we got our big radar dish
and
let's see do we always need a seam do
you always want to go for a seam
if i go to edge mode and just click that
guy there it'll unwrap from that point
perhaps
or we could do it from like you know
maybe this or something
it'll unwrap from there let's see what
it looks like
um let's go ahead and save i'll switch
over to
the uv edit layout
and let's control
a no we didn't need to do that
i think that's fine as is
let me just try to unwrap it and see
what it looks like
uh that is not correct
definitely not correct um let's try
selecting all these edges and try it
again or all the faces rather
i can totally see why uh learning how to
uv
well can take so much time it's
it's very confusing very confusing i i
never really understood it
um i i barely understand it
i just know you have to get your
checkerboard is looking nice
okay so i hit uv unwrap again and it
kind of
it did a better job here so maybe
we can work with this i don't know
um i'm going to save this
and i'm going to re-import with the data
smith importer actually no no i'm going
to go to
content let's close this out
i'm going to go to my data smith
infrastructure for steve i'm going to
right click it and just
re-import the very top option
uh yep
boom and we'll see what happens
give it a second here
okay let's go in what is it f
focus yep this you have to select it
first yeah
and then focus yep um
it kind of looks the same to be honest
kind of looks exactly the same
what was that world thing so you did it
with the world
uh settings what if i just try a normal
one like materials
with like a ceramic tile checkerboard
oh yeah if you didn't change your
material from the world space it should
look the exact same
yeah this looks way worse
dang why does this have to be so
complicated all i want to do is
do art i don't have to do all this
unwrapping stuff
oh wow okay okay interesting
this is something okay so this tells me
it's a scale thing now yeah yes
so that honestly looks pretty rad though
[Music]
is this some instance or is this the
master
okay that you have i guess that's the
master isn't it
i need to make an instance of that and
then i have to
i guess do like a scale parameter on it
um where'd it go it's not chilling okay
there it is
all right let's see if we can
we can do this oh god
we want up in here what is it a
u what is it u or texture coordinate
yup texture coordinate and then multiply
m for multiply and click
and that goes to a parameter that's s
hold s and click scale
pipe that in to the b and that goes into
the uvs
and you want to include that and
everything that has a uv slot so
you hit c you can make a comment on it
and just call that uvs
and i'll pipe this into everything
that has the option it already has it
large scale tiling it looks like well
let's let's see what this does maybe
that's a separate thing um and then
normal let's plug it into the normal
awesome cool save this master material
how you doing on your end steve
i'm doing pretty good i got foliage
going the right way i accidentally
made it only spawn in the radar dish
nice
but it's looking better it's looking a
lot better
you can see this is all uh
a little bit randomized for the rotation
still but it's
going up instead of tangential to the
slopes themselves
then i was gonna just sculpt the
landscape a little bit and just
raise it up to these towers
this is such a touchy tool
there we go you'll need to smooth that
out so it doesn't look like it's on a
plateau it's super cool though it's like
the the forest is kind of growing up
into the radar dish a little bit or into
those towers i like that
yeah and if i use the flatten we can get
like a nice
slope here looks like a bit of a cliff
there we go it's gonna need some noise
though
0.1 like 256.
let's do 64.
this is like kind of working
the uh material yeah
like this is i'll switch over like
i think this kind of gets us what we
want in a way
i i might get rid of these like
tubular pieces but this is like your
checkered tile
going across this thing um
from a distance can look pretty pretty
nice
my friend uh marshall miller really
awesome 3d artist
and creative technologist as well he
asked if there's a uv stretcher
in cinema 4d um totally i know there's
there there is okay and octane yeah
there's like
octopus i'm i'm very i'm not the best
with uvs and stuff because
basically the way i do it is i'll go
into octane and i'll just change it from
the mesh uv
to a box projection
and then i can tile it from there it's
all kind of built into
their what's the best way to
to show this i really do need to up my
uv game
um let's see let's go to stream
do uh uv issues only tend to present
themselves when you're working with
unreal or do you tend to struggle with
uvs
within cinema and octane as well no i'm
fine in cinema and octane
like i just switch it to box and i'll
like
tile it you know or i'll do like a
tri-planer and just like kind of mesh
everything together in box form
um but i just don't know how to do that
in unreal
um like i feel like your uvs have to be
a lot more specific
in unreal which is why you know
it's difficult for me it's certainly
difficult for me
yeah definitely takes time but i think
this is good
i'm gonna probably start texturing this
i'm just gonna get get down to it and
start texturing
this thing sweet
landscape's looking good got some nice
foliage
nice that looks awesome
let's get uh man we're even gonna be
able to get like some nice views from
like the side of this with like some
cool shadows
oh i love exploiting sense of scale
in unreal that's gonna be really cool
i noticed that there's a lot of uh
this was like a very like smooth bowl
around the edge so i'm just gonna like
paint in
some trees uh the same ones we're
currently using just not procedural here
keep the density set to
like 0.5
4k size that's a bit much
i also don't want it in the satellite
itself
settings current level yep yep
that is some fun lod popping i have to
adjust that later on
i'd like this bumpy area to have
a bit less yeah
all right go back to the select tool
that i don't like that just have to
dip the terrain down a little bit i
think dude i got a chrome
freaking radar dish right now
looking super high-tech
that's intense oh man that looks like
the uh the reference i saw the nasa
reference
the other day yeah get the sun coming
off of this thing
that's ridiculous
the texturing is so much fun for me man
i love it
so yeah this is the master material that
we set up uh let me show you guys
a pretty sweet little setup here um
so we got your uvs here which steve set
up this like material function if you
double click and go into it
it's got a lot of fun stuff and this is
all just basically like
all these little settings here the input
offset uh input scale
x and y offset x and y rotation
you know we saw you saw us just do this
right here this texture coordinate this
is a custom rotator
it allows you to rotate your stuff and
it's set up through an ad and a multiply
for scale and for offset
and if i
yeah so that's all kind of just piped
into this little piece here
and it's called a function material
function is that right
yep yep so if you double click that you
can see yeah
it goes in yeah and then we just right
clicked all this stuff
and promote to parameter which i don't
think that option is
uh we can't click it because we already
did it but all this stuff was promoted
to parameters
um this is basically like if you're an
octane
and you set up a whole octane material
with everything
this is this is all surface
imperfections so this is all roughness
this is like your base roughness if you
have a material from like mega skins or
something you just plug that roughness
channel in
and then it goes to
you have two options basically like
steve told me about this cool switcher
that
this like switch parameter was it called
what's the name of it
a static switch parameter yep so you can
switch with the check box
whether it's true or false if it's false
it just uses a random
random noise with this is another one of
steve's
material functions if we go in here you
can see like he set up all this
craziness
where it's mixing between three
different uh
uh three different textures at different
scales to get you like a random
kind of a kind of a look so that's
that's a way that we can do
some smudginess and some general
can break up our roughness and add some
imperfections or if you
want to use specific imperfections like
you guys know i have my
imperfection pack i can drop that into
here and
this is all the same thing this material
function just controls
its scale and it's offset and we should
probably have rotation
but yep yeah there it is um
it's plugged into multiply with for an
intensity and then all of this is
plugged into one final multiply for the
overall intensity and it's clamped here
at the end
so it doesn't go beyond and like give
you weird weird looks that might
potentially be an issue
and that's plugged into roughness
metallic is very simple it's just on or
off
zero to one base color
is a a diffuse texture here
you just hit t left click and it makes a
makes that little node there that you
can plug any texture into
the multiply is going into what is this
a
three would you call that if you
hold three and click it makes a what is
that
so that's a constant three uh value
which is just rgb
or xyz uh but it's also uh when it's a
parameter
it's a vector parameter and it's gonna
be able to give you uh
instance you can iterate on so that'll
give you color um
that you can tint it with in a multiply
and desaturate
is just a straight-up desaturate node i
guess right that goes into a
parameter that you can by the way all
these parameters
they're custom so you just hit hold s
and left click and you can type whatever
you want
and then that'll pop up in your material
instance you don't want to use the
master material every time just like in
cinema
or blender like you don't want to copy
500 boxes and
have them all be a dynamic you want to
have one box with 499 instances of that
box
so that you're being as smart as
possible with how you set all this stuff
up
um so that's desaturating it it's just
giving us a lot of
a lot of possibilities and control over
our diffuse channel
and then finally we have this switcher
so if you don't have a diffuse color and
you just want it to be
sorry if you don't if you don't have a
diffuse uh texture
then you can just have it be a color
whatever color you want so you can hit
that little check box
that's going into diffuse and then of
course we have a normal
you know most textures come with a
normal map you plug in
that's in a flattened normal node and
basically in a another parameter called
flatten which is basically like the
intensity so you can you can chill it
out
set it to set it to one if you set the
flat into one it'll just
take all your normal away so that is
the master material from there i'm right
clicking that master material
and at the very i believe at the very
top
um it says create material instance
um i'll show you guys show you guys it
real quick so you just right click that
create material instance
um and that is
my satellite material
so there's a lot of really good comments
coming through right now
um what what we put together for this
master material
is very elaborate so i hope no one feels
like
the the learning curve is too steep for
unreal based on like that giant
spaghetti that we just showed
it's extremely versatile you can see all
these options that clint has because of
all those parameters
that were set up you could just as
easily have like a brick material that's
just
textures that you made in substance or
quicksole or something
and you'd be good but the reason we have
it set up this way is so we can just
like add
so many options and tons of detail
and just iterate quicker and quicker and
quicker so
there's a lot of stuff you can make
there's no
well there are wrong ways to do it but
there's a lot of right ways to do it too
so there's obviously a lot to learn but
uh what clint just showed is
um a very elaborate way to go about it
and uh someone else also mentioned like
optimization
if this was a game uh
and we had so many uh draw calls
happening and
um all these different parameters it
would
be pretty chunky uh and there are ways
to design around that
but our goal here again is just like
something cool and cinematic so
not too worried about hitting you know
90 frames a second here
yeah exactly
so i'm just kind of messing with the
material instance and i can plug in
any surface imperfections i want i can
search for any normal maps or whatever
but i can also
again i can go to like uh quixote mega
scans
which you guys have seen me use all the
time and just find a material that works
there which i might do as well it'll be
probably a combination of that um mr one
dead duck
thank you for the super chat good to see
you man and he says remember
the sliding pierce brosnan first story
yeah we gotta
gotta put a little little james bond in
there slide down
hilarious yeah one dead duck he he's a
really good artist and
constantly wins these uh these render
challenges
that i host every single week um
really good guy
so i might just
like that's that's crazy looking super
intense
maybe the metallic being set to like 0.5
so we're still getting a little bit of
that base material in there
like that almost looks like a military
gray if you add
a sphere reflection capture yes on top
of that
that'll help with the color ooh okay
yeah let's try it
do i have to bake stuff how does that
work or um
do i have to build sorry no
maybe we'll see spherical reflection
capture and let's get that
guy up probably like right in the middle
right here
yeah and uh move it up too so it's not
here
right outside of it yeah that's that's
good and you want the
scale of it to be sorry the influence
radius to be
um more than the geometry itself
so i set mine to like 30 000 and that
sphere of
influence is um kind of capturing all of
the
bits that might be metallic and this
will help us
get more accurate color values we are
using real-time retracing
but having reflection captures in there
as well
that adds some of the additional detail
to it
um and then don't hit build
but hit the drop down next to it and go
down to
build reflection captures yeah
it's quick yeah wait it's finished yep
didn't really do anything um
you're in lit mode i'm also not
reflecting anything but like i guess the
the clouds
i don't know yeah that's true um
maybe dip down the roughness yeah
uh roughness 0.1
i mean if i just straight full metallic
chrome city
zero roughness this is what we're
looking at
ab i appreciate that super chat thank
you so much
i'm having a great day it's super chill
yeah it's a good one
all right i'm just keep cranking here um
let me just switch over to you while i
work on this and figure some stuff out
yeah
yeah go for it i got some cool stuff to
show sweet
all right anya all right so
um i cleaned up some of the trees uh
up to the distance of that foliage i'm
actually getting pretty good frame rate
so i'm pretty happy with that
re-enabled shadows um on some of the
distant trees we can kind of see
i'm not worried about shadows on the
ground quite yet we might just fill that
in with just like more density for the
trees
um but i guess we'll see so uh
one thing i want to add is some
variation to all of the green because
this looks very uniform um
so there's a really cool node we can add
let me find
the tree here's our sm tree medium one
we'll use that to start right of paul
thank you
super chats i got you i'm gonna sneak
some of those in there steve apologies
yeah absolutely i really appreciate you
guys um it means a lot
uh he's like yo let me know when you're
gonna go full time after all this
or not full time full real time i don't
know man maybe one day
i still love octane
octane's quick though it's not it's not
a slow program right
no brigade will be coming out soon which
is which is their full-time earth
their real-time option so
that'll be sweet dang so
uh it looks like all of the foliage in
this aspect pack i'm using has three
materials set up already
uh this imposter which i'm assuming if
i'm at like a really long
distance it'll just sub it out with
just like a a billboard essentially
and then we get a material for the
leaves and one for the bark
i'm worried about the the leaves and i'm
hoping
this mi tree medium fo is used for
all of the trees or maybe just like this
master material is using it for all of
them
i could affect how much wind there is if
we look in the scene
i'm good with that if anyone in puerto
rico
could uh let us know how windy it is out
there what the weather's like maybe we
can try to
simulate that um we got some tree sway
leaves in the wind that's good
subsurface scattering that's good
i want randomness
so i can open the master material and uh
going into base color i want to add a
node
called speed tree
color variation and what this does
is it adds color variation
uh so i'm just gonna sneak it in after
the color
texture and all that i'm gonna add a
parameter called
color variation
look at that default to zero i'm going
to bump that up
0.2 see that is it's going to take
a year to compile those shaders so i'm
going to
wait a couple minutes uh but we'll see
that shortly
um so mark uh is jumping into unreal
from five plus years working with c4d
and uh he's loving all these tutorials
so shout outs to you mark thanks for uh
thanks for learning with us
and thanks to steve man thanks for
joining me on this it's
it's fun we're i feel like we're halfway
there you know like we
we're just tweaking we're getting things
to look nice and we're gonna
we're gonna tweak the lighting and get
the fog going all nice and stuff and
get a final render i'm excited yeah
it's definitely coming along and looking
really cool
uh so yeah i'm still compiling shaders
um so in the meantime
let's tweak some lighting so one thing i
like to do
i'm going to be messing with primarily
the directional light
skylight exponential height fog sky
atmosphere post process
i could dump all those in a folder and
just
like mess with the hierarchy and do all
that
what i typically do
this string uh filter result here
another cool thing i think this is a new
sf426 if you go up to
window you get a really cool panel that
gives you
um all of your environment stuff and a
really cool
and easy to use way i never use it
uh so i'm just gonna do it my way expo
uh atmo post there we go
so let's look at the uh let's add clouds
in there too
and someone asked if this is the free
jungle pack and
yes it definitely is
saving us a lot of time really nice
assets
um if we're exposure to here if it's
getting a little laggy apologies i am
importing from mega scans and i think
that uh
i think that chunks it up a little bit
but i think we're good
now i think nope it's auto saving
getting a lot of f's in chat yes
i think it's just like a little laggy or
something but we'll be done
this is forcing me to do it on my own
without mega scans now
i think we're good now though i think
we're good if you guys are feeling good
thumbs ups all around if it's back to
normal
sounds good to me seems yep seems good
all right um i'm looking at the exposure
and uh just trying to set up like a
interesting shadow
to fall across the satellite dish i'd
like
a good like splash of light on the back
and then a good like
crescent shadow would be cool it'd be
nice if we could get a shot
like this where there's like light
coming from around the tower
like some volumetric yes effect might be
cool yeah like like some uh god rays
coming
basically if if what you're saying is
singing syncing up with what i'm saying
it's basically like you have
a volumetric kind of foggy light
on one half of the radar dish
like kind of like you have it right now
you have the the shadow cutting into the
middle of it but it's
almost has like a god ray effect to it
or something
check this out this is horrible for
optimization
things might crash i'm going to do a
save all
in the directional light if we have
volumetric fog enabled
which we do we can enable light shaft
occlusion
and light shaft bloom so now if i find
the sun
[Music]
we should get yes there it is a little
bit something
oh obviously
looks bad right now but we could uh
bump up the fog change the settings for
the darkness for the occlusion
and we'll have something really cool
there um
yeah so i like the uh
i like coming across there i typically
don't mess with
the um skylight
intensity scale but let's what would it
look like
okay we could do that to like dump some
contrast in there
volumetric clouds those are like
i wish i could get like some bigger
chunky clouds layer bottom altitude
some cumulus clouds perhaps
that's the word i thought it was chonky
clouds
oh boy look at that just changed one
parameter and it's
immediately so different
yup yup bass noise scale
oh man
whether uv albedo yep that's good good
hey this finally finished i forgot about
it it's
been a while all right so i'm going to
save this and we're going to have color
variation
defaulting to 0.2 and this is going to
look at the
texture which is multiplying against a
rgb value
and then multiplying that by 0.2 in
either direction
up or down completely randomly so every
instance of every tree in the world
should have 20 randomness might look
like we have some
blue and amber-ish trees in there
but uh we can tweak that because it's a
parameter
it's going to take a while are you doing
anything interesting want to cut to you
sure yeah i kind of have like a
i'm using a dirty pool tile from uh from
mega scans to
kinda get something like this you know
a little checkerboard going across all
this stuff and i'm just tweaking the
like the reflectivity of all this to try
and really
really match it to the reference here um
so i might want to take like the diffuse
um so you guys can see here this is like
the mega scans master material
or material instance and you can see all
these little
you know little pieces here that it
gives you options for these are all just
parameters that they named
um so if i wanted to
go into the albedo and tint it or maybe
the controls yeah the brightness go up
like two or something or three i kind of
want to have like a
an off-white kind of a look almost
military gray
um
and have that chipped away and all nasty
on like the edges and stuff and it's
obviously like the texture itself is
kind of doing it
but that's on the micro level i want it
on the macro level and i'm not quite
sure how i'm gonna do that yet
um oh man that looks awesome
that's gonna be a tough one i think i
might have it scaled down a little too
much
um we could go to
the global tiling yeah just set it to
like
40 instead of 50.
you know we could add uh decals on top
as well
oh like a rust sort of texture that
might be the move
mm-hmm definitely might be the move
i'm trying to catch the light
in an interesting way and i think
i need to be like over here
to really there it is there it is that's
what i need
you mind if i address some of these
questions while you're doing that yeah
of course you want me to switch to you
or you
just want to talk about uh i'm i'm still
saving it's it's chugging
uh someone said vertex painting answer
yes
um big fan it is uh
definitely gonna be helpful here um one
of the limitations
is you're bound to how many vertices are
on the object itself
so that might mean we have to um
up the tessellation on the model uh we
could figure that out but
um our master material is not currently
set up for it so we might just
make a new one and incorporate that
decals always a great way to go and
there's a ton of awesome mega scans
assets there
[Music]
someone else was asking about education
specifically for vfx
and unreal development
i i'm completely self-taught with this
there's a ton of awesome free tutorials
and live streams
like this one where you can learn all
sorts of cool stuff
but art institutes uh
any art school out there uh everyone's
getting into real time
there's amazing programs uh
so many free awesome resources
especially with this community it's
really easy to learn these sweet new
programs
yeah big fan absolutely
oh man color variation worked
uh looks bad oh it looks real bad
looks like camouflage it's just too much
uh yeah it's uh yeah it's way too much
way way too much um let's see
there's that i'll just take color
variation
and this is only going to affect one
type of tree
and you can see those ones there and a
.05
let's find where this is
finds tropic okay yeah so tropic was the
other tree i was using i believe
there we go all right we get some uh
stuff going on here but overall the tops
of the trees
looks much better oh that's the shadow
from the tower i thought it was
an artifact that's awesome
set this to maybe like uh 0.05
ooh too much it's very touchy
0.0 0.035 um
[Music]
0.035 yes
and vines let's make this point of three
five as well
through five oh boy
it's feeling good
question for you so
how do i if i want to
just color this edge a specific
uh texture but it's obviously going to
apply to the whole thing
how do i isolate this edge
and basically all these pipes down here
do i need to just go back into c4d
isolate the the object re-import it
yeah so you want just a different
material channel there yeah
essentially yeah yeah uh if you go into
c4d and i believe you just
add a separate material to that part
when you
import it it'll be a second channel yeah
in that case if i'm going to c4d i might
as well just
you know do a loop selection and get get
this stuff
yeah i think i'll do that i think i'm
just going to get the rest of this stuff
like this
and we're probably not going to see all
that we you're covering up the bottom of
this radar with
the ground right yes
it's not like touching the ground we
might be able to get some cool angles
from like alongside the bottom
might be cool so i don't want to dismiss
it but
it'll be there yeah okay my focus is
definitely the inside of it
right now yeah we'll figure out uh
we'll figure out the rest let's see
what's the best way to
get all of this maybe
oh i know someone said there's got to be
a way to make material selections in
unreal
there is if we go back to that
static mesh editor we were showing
before where you can like flip faces and
stuff
you can select by element and create
material channel that way
but again if you're going to your 3d
program to
clean stuff up or do something
differently anyway you're probably
better off doing it there
but that's that's a really good question
and that was a
hot feature when that came out and
highly requested so
is a very nice to have
i'm gonna add some uh mega scans
what do you think maybe like some cliffs
large rocks
always yeah here gotta get those i'll
switch to you
i'm just selecting polygons
all right so i was looking doing some
research as you do about puerto rico uh
the geology there is as i understand it
a lot of like
volcanic rock um i don't know like
i haven't been there obviously i i don't
know what exactly like the typical
puerto rican rock
looks like but uh it made me think of
the asset pack of mega scans for iceland
so we could actually pull
volcanic rock from mega scans of a
different continent
and as long as there's no like you know
greenery or foliage people might not
know that it's a different biome
entirely so i'm going to search
volcanic rock let's see what we get
tons of great assets iceland
yep let's do assets
and i'm going to look for something that
we can scale way up
that's not going to look like trash
a lot of these are just like smaller
little areas okay well they have that
scale feature too which is really nice
our our face is currently blocking it ah
let me see if
i got to move you over yeah the little
scale that person
you see that person um like where it
says open
the material is open or the object is
open there are stats down there you have
a scale one
uh it's just above the related assets
yeah whoa so it's like a person and then
that like the rectangle is how big the
thing is so
sometimes you'll sometimes you'll like
click on a rock and you're like this
rock looks huge but it's just a pebble
and like god dang it
yeah um that's been a common thing i've
been trying to avoid lately
is like i'll take like this awesome lava
cliff
and i'll like duplicate it through the
scene a few times and take one and scale
it way up and suddenly you see
like the little patches of lichen on
there and it's like
huge yeah uh so that's really awesome to
see um
i'm so glad they added that and it's an
assembly yup
um okay i might come back and grab a few
more but
just to get ahead of compiling shaders i
did add a couple
already um so i'll hop in
[Music]
and go to where those imported oh i'll
show how how to import as well since
we're here
so i already installed the plugin
if you don't have it already you can go
manage plugins choose unreal i'm in
426 again so that's all good to go
we could use 4k resolution
um we'll probably be okay with 2k
i forget which one i imported but as
soon as you download it you just export
and if your project is open it'll just
pop right in there
it'll build the levels of detail compile
shaders for you and everything
um is the best super super quick yeah
if you ever have a problem where it
doesn't come in automatically and you're
not getting an
error check to see if you have a project
open in the background maybe it's like
going to that one instead get that all
the time
all right so um that came in and we got
these cliffs
looking good let's uh
start adding some of these so i'm going
to take this lava cliff
again keeping uniform scale
i'm just going to break up the terrain a
little bit
clint did you go to like
uh college for video production vfx
anything like that or are you mostly
self-taught
i'm mostly self-taught i went to um
a tech school called chattahoochee tech
in georgia
and i was there for about a year and a
half um
they taught after effects and photoshop
in illustrator and i think
there was a c4d class but i honestly
i was already teaching myself with video
copilot um
and my teacher my after effects teacher
let me work on my youtube channel as a
grade
he was the best and he that's all he's
the one who actually like
kind of convinced my dad to let me move
out here
and drop out of college he was like yeah
if you got the job
just go for it you can always come back
he said that
we go to college so that we can get the
job and if you already have the job then
there's no point to like continue
that was his that was his opinion on it
and it was enough to convince my dad to
be like
all right go for it so mr mason
shout outs to mr mason thanks mr mason
chattahoochee tech
all right these cliffs are looking good
i'm trying to like angle them a little
bit and hide the seams
under the ground but um
yeah that'll just help to break
everything up a little bit maybe get
this
icelandic lava spire as well that would
look
awesome near one of these towers so if i
have
yeah like getting those towers to like
kind of be up on a little rocky surface
would be sweet
i'm still in the forest but like kind of
surrounded in that rock oh dude i can't
wait to get that fog going
i hope my textures don't screw it up
like your textures
kind of look better than mine already
this this one here this is still the uh
default brick
it looks good i think it just needs you
just need to up the reflectivity in it
or like lower the roughness or something
to be killer
whoa man if i was an octane if only i
was an
octane god dang it so confusing it's
like i know exactly what i would want to
do if it was an octane but it's an
unreal and i'm like
[Music]
one day
one day all right knowing i'm gonna get
a camera view from over here
i'm gonna dip down this landscape then
go to sculpt there we go 0.1
good good good 0.5 let's make this like
20 000.
oh that was a mistake
no that'll be good
yep cliff goes right there
you get a nice rocky outcrop next to
this
maybe i'll uh rotate that so we get a
little bit more visibility
i don't want it peeking out from the
landscape
oh yeah
you know a quick shout out to all the
moderators here
appreciate you guys um helping moderate
the chat answering questions and stuff
they're also the moderators on my
discord server if you guys want to join
that
we do weekly challenges every single
week uh the link's
it's in the description but yeah shout
outs to the mods they've been helping
out a lot
and um i'll touch on this a little bit
more once we get to the
art review at the end of this thing um
but we have an instagram now it's the
create with clint instagram
and all of the weekly challenge winners
are posted there
or will be posted there we're populating
it you know a couple times a week
um so shout outs to the moderators who
worked really hard to get that going
it's just a cool place to be able to
feature all of your guys's art and
get as many as many clicks on it and get
as many people looking at your stuff as
possible so
create with clint on instagram
follow it see all your cool art
something
really cool and magical just happened
uh a couple seconds ago i just wanted to
point this out i was rotating this rock
and i realized it was getting like a
little dark like
you know sometimes you're outside doing
stuff and
the sun goes behind a cloud and suddenly
it's like a little bit darker i was like
why
why is my screen darker and i looked and
the sun
was actually behind some clouds and it
was real time
dimming my scene because of that it's so
crazy
unbelievable
that's amazing
yeah this program is sweet
i'm a fanboy i'll admit
some more clips in here
there we go sneak that under the ground
all right do you want to talk about uh
some camera angles
ooh um
we can um i was thinking that we could
i could send my textures to you
and then we could do camera angles and
lighting
together i'm still trying to wrap
out this texture unless unless you just
want to throw
some some reflection on that stone
i think it actually kind of it kind of
works yeah it kind of works
if it's far enough away um maybe like
lower the roughness and uh
up the metallic so it catches the
sunlight
really nicely okay let's walk everyone
through this so this isn't the starter
content this is a brick material i'm
going to duplicate it i'm going to call
it mm for master material
brick shiny again
super creative pop that in our material
folder
and wait
this is the best part i'm just so
excited okay here we go
uh mm brick shiny so this is gonna be
the same graph we had in there
they're doing some cool stuff uh same
thing i had that material function i
stole it from unreal starter content uh
we have some randomness let's add
uh we have some time to go through some
parameter stuff
for materials yeah i mean
yeah i i would assume so we were only
two hours in you know we
we can go to four hours if we want so
yeah man
all right this is some good important
content to cover too so
happy too you're making a parameter here
are you just trying to get like a
scaling
situation going right so there's uh
some procedural noise going on semi
procedural they're just layering uh
three macro variation texture so i'm
going to add just a
master uh parameter to scale
that so we can just scrub that value and
get like some
splotchiness that's a little more
intentional
macro contrast i'm going to
uh make that a parameter as well
call it macro contrast
yo real quick shout out here to sai sai
charon
um says he got a salt a salt rock lamp
at home to get a closer look at it
and he loves it um gave it a shot in
blender and it looks really good
and uh thanks he says thanks for the
live streams dude i got you
um the salt rock lamps are the best i
love them i got two beside me last week
we did a salt rock lamp pbr
texture and it turned out so nice so so
nice
um so that was a good one but man thanks
for the super chat i appreciate you
rock on man
so i'm adding another parameter here to
scale
uh the brick texture itself so i'm going
to call this scale x and we're appending
that
to a scale y
i swear i've done this a thousand times
before set
both of these default to one custom
rotator this is going to be the
uv rotation default to zero rotation
angle boom boom
uh okay take this and we also want that
to go to the brick
normal and the roughness
is what
what oh okay i thought these were going
the wrong way
okay so uh this is uh the alpha
of this what we see here uh i don't know
if you can see behind the checkerboard
yeah that is uh determining the amount
of roughness where that
is uh transparent is
point four currently where there is
texture it is point eight
i'm going to make both of these
parameters so i'm going to call this
roughness
minimum call this one
roughness maximum
and then they're doing a really cool
thing with normals down here which is
really really awesome and versatile so
they're taking this noise texture
multiplying it so it's just like
ginormous
and adding some contrast to it and then
they're getting
pixel depth and what this does is every
point on the screen it's getting the
distance between
your view in in the viewport and that
pixel where is an xyz
so essentially making a depth pass and
then
using that they're doing some math to to
change the fall off
and then blending between this normal
texture
and flat and what that does
is at a distance if we were like way way
back here
there's no normal at all but if we are
close there is a normal and that helps
with some optimization
helps with like better aliasing at a
distance so that's
super awesome um i just want to make
some of these into parameters so we can
control that on our own
so convert to parameter call this uh
large scale transition
distance
large scale transition scale
cool cool and look at that we have a ton
of shaders we get to compile
and let this minimize for a little while
it can do its thing
that's all uh a cpu operation
and if you have multi-threading enabled
and you have a
really awesome cpu that can go way
faster
uh also i have a lot of things running
on my computer right now so it's kind of
slow but um clint i know you have
much faster shader compiling than i do
it's practically real time for you
yeah i got the basically the the the
quadro
6k so the step up from from the 4k
but that certainly helps but it's insane
that you're on a laptop
it's just ridiculous
i'm going to default metallic to zero as
well and specular
i'll default that to 0.5
uh i saw someone on twitter uh
recommended this they they said they
always put metallic and specular because
those are
typically for a lot of stuff that people
do
uh just a zero to one value uh so just
like nesting those to the right
of your final outputs
that's like a fun little thing to do
that's what the cool kids do that's the
way i understood it
all right so that's good
and as soon as that's done we can see
what it's like
um what are you working on over there
i'm just kind of working on like
the material that is going on the towers
um got it so i'm just it's very basic
it's just like a using our material
uh instance or our master material i'm
just kind of like giving a little bit of
metallic giving it a little bit of
roughness
and trying to find a nice like
kind of matte shiny matte white
material that would be nice to have like
a
a dirt node i don't know how to do a
dirt node
in unreal um
but that would help with like basically
all of the
all the crevices and the cracks and give
it some dirt up in there to make it look
like there's a bit more depth to it
if you uh stick on your screen for
a couple minutes i'll whip something
together
for that it's gonna be awesome is there
a way to add it to the master material
that we made
so we can have that as an option like a
dirt option or something
yes yes there is um
how are we going to do that
do you know how off the top of your head
yes uh i'll do it on
my end okay if you'd like yes and i will
i can walk you through it
follow along i'm switching to you
and let me go ahead and save this real
quick
and i guess open up our master material
i guess
yeah um i do i have that master material
we made
i don't think i do uh but you can throw
it wherever you want i can just include
it in mine here
okay yeah so uh this
is just a um material function test
material i was working on so i'll show
you in here so
i have this material functions uh folder
that i shared with client a couple days
ago this has
a function to offset and scale
uvs which is awesome this adds a
randomized noise like we saw with the
splotchiness and the scaling
[Music]
distance gradient is what we saw with
those normals fading away
further from the camera but this one
distance field blend
what this does is if we double click it
and open
this utilizes those mesh distance fields
that we enabled at the very start of the
project
and what this does is it takes the
absolute world position again the
xyz position of each vertex
of the object that this material is
applied to does
distance to nearest surface so it
outputs a zero to one value well
i'm not sure it outputs a value um
and then we're doing some math and we're
we're taking this noise
and then multiplying that by value for
intensity
adding power for contrast clamping at
zero to one
so what we can do is essentially get
a noise fall off which would look a lot
like
an ambient occlusion map but noisy
so we
we can use this output to essentially
linear interpolate between
um say your texture of
brick and uh
like black or texture for rust okay
something like that
and then plug that into base color so
then you'd want to add a couple
parameters for
these material functions here multiply
contrast and scale
well okay so you have a three parameter
in b
looks like or you could do a texture
um yeah black i think will work for
whatever we're doing right now
and then yeah what's uh an alpha what is
that oops
so alpha so uh linear interpolate
um imagine if you will a graph
x and y uh you have a point
up here you have a point down here uh
linear interpolate basically draws a
line between those two and
alpha tells you where between those
on that line you are um
[Music]
a simpler way to think of it is it's
like
alpha is saying how much of a or how
much of b
if this value is zero
um the output is going to be a hundred
percent
a if this is one
the output would be 100 whatever's in b
so if this is 0.5
obviously it's going to blend 50 50 just
overlay for the output point to you know
just a scale uh but if this is like a
texture
then it's like mixing those two based on
so it's like a mixed node in octane
it's exactly a mixed node in octane
that's crazy
yeah and someone says it's like a color
ramp in blender
not familiar with it but cool that's
awesome
what is in your alpha right now i can't
read it because it's not a tiny screen
for me
oh sorry right now alpha is plugged into
the output of uh the material function
distance field blend that i gave you oh
wait wait hold on what's an a then
a is just the texture that um
that does not that is
so b is the color
of the grunginess in all the cracks a
would be like the metal or like the
paint or
background that isn't grungy got it and
then
that's determined by this getting into
the weeds everyone but that's okay we're
here to learn
um if that's going to be part of our
master material
would that like whatever we decide
for the master material should be the a
then right yes so then should we plug in
the hat that has diffuse texture
up in our in our up in our in our base
color master material
that has diffuse texture a little
switcher
that would go into basically the a
right yes okay amazing
you could even add another static switch
parameter here to say
does it use this material function
distance field blend
so you can turn it on and turn it off
when you want to
got you that is amazing
well i'm going to just crash course this
i'm going to see if i can try it and see
if it works out
and all that goes in the diffuse texture
the base color amazing
still compiling shaders but i'll work on
some lighting in the meantime
uh let's see so we got plenty of trees
[Music]
um
if i go in here uh right now it's only
set to
build uh procedural foliage on landscape
itself
but i can set it so it builds on rocks
as well
well then it would build on these now
i'll keep it as is
that's all right but i might up the
density
oh yeah so many options so many check
boxes
one thing i found is that if you um if
you have a bug and you're
just like stuck on some roadblock
you probably just haven't found the
right checkbox yet
dude that's like relationship advice
right there dude
i don't mean to get too deep here but if
you have roadblocks in your life
you just haven't found the right
checkbox
some random arbitrary values here
height that's good pitch normal
yep yep yep
seeds per step what about scale
procedural scale one to three
yeah so procedural foliage tree one and
two
those have the same height so i'm just
gonna bump one of these up
just give it a little bit more window
see my three and four those are the same
[Music]
we are so close to finishing with these
shaders
i'm so excited
shadows that's good okay
so now now that i updated the settings
for the foliage themselves i can
re-simulate and we should see an update
yep there we go
a little bit more randomness i would
like to see
maybe more density
yeah i'm just going to pop open purif
and look at some of these
the the tree okay so a lot more clips a
lot more
ridges um
[Music]
but it's just like a sea of green yeah
really yeah
their trees are uh sorry they're trees
the real trees
are um very bushy
very thick
it's like uh it's it's very much
like florida in my experience
and geographically i guess that makes
sense um
so i guess i could
yeah i'm just going to go crazy with the
density
all right i'm working on this dirt layer
thing if i figure it out
i'll be sure to switch over and fill
everyone in right
number steps for clustering let's go up
to three for these
save that re-simulate i always hold my
breath when i resimulate i'm always
worried it's gonna like
as soon as i do it just crash everything
and
all right uh so it's not adding more
because our limiting factor here is the
amount of radius around each tree itself
so i want to be sure that they can spawn
in shade
as trees tend to do
[Music]
that add that
save all
re-simulate okay very slight change
not much but at the same time this shiny
brick
finally finished so we can play with
that a little bit
i feel like after this stream
i could just cut together like a 10
minute video of
my loading bars and that's it it's just
silence it's like
yeah it's just how to do this and unreal
and it's just loading bars and us just
like staring at the screen with their
mouths open
that's hilarious all right let's
load this up uh yeah we have
uh material and brick shiny if we right
click that
create material instance i'm going to
call this mi brick
shiny one
throw it on there oh boy here we go
so all of these i'm just gonna check
them so i can
iterate real quick
uv rotation zero macro contrast all
right
so let's look at the scale of the bricks
themselves
first uh right now it's one and one
[Music]
i could stretch it so it looks more like
the actual tiles that we see oh
hello could be cool like 0.02
no no 0.2
and then
0.3 0.1
honestly not bad
i think it just needs it needs that
reflectivity so if you look at the sun
basically look at the shadow side of the
the dish so that the sun kind of like
bounces off
uh orbit around counter clock or
clockwise
clockwise uh other way yeah
yeah and try and try and get a
reflection yeah yeah try and make that
reflection a little sharper
you know what i mean so i think the
roughness just needs to come down
um maybe bring the metallic up a little
bit or something
yeah something like this okay so
yeah so uh minimum is controlling
where the actual bricks are and maximum
is
essentially the grout between those so i
want to flip that yeah
so all set maximum to
zero and minimum 0.2
0.3 yeah or
yeah that's good that's not bad and then
i would try and go for more of that
white
so i'd i'd adjust the the
potentially the brightness the
saturation um in the diffuse
you know okay okay um
people say whenever you have a pbr
material always keep the metallic zero
or
one you should never do something
between zero and one
but what if
why why is it always
like never in the middle it makes no
sense because
as i understand it realistically uh
any object in the world is either
metallic
or not metallic got you there's no like
semi-metallic
but if you have like a like rusty metal
where the metal itself is
completely metallic yeah obviously but
the rust is not then you'd have like a
texture feeding it
and that would be zero and one value so
like completely black and white
but i find like sometimes you can get
like a nice like pearly
sort of uh material by doing this uh and
sometimes it's nice for like glass and
water to like
put a little bit of metallic in there
but interesting
maybe i shouldn't yeah uh okay so you're
saying
make the material like more white so
i go into brick shiny
i'm sure someone's going to correct me
on everything i just said about metallic
and non-metallic
and i look forward to reading that and
getting some real education
i'm going to duplicate the brick t brick
white i'm going to sub that in here
open that yeah someone said if you have
metal with
dust on top it would be a blend that's a
good note yeah
okay so uh the texture editor in unreal
this is completely
non-destructive so after you import all
your textures
substance photoshop whatever it's
nice to be able to like come in here and
just like remove a little bit of desatur
or uh
saturation and like add some curves to
it
um and then when you re-import it's like
keeping these settings these are on top
of everything you did in your previous
program so
this is nice especially for like the
developer working with an artist to like
take the stuff someone else did and just
like modify it a little bit to
fit the scene a little better a lot of
times i get like
sketchup files where the diffuse
textures are completely saturated and
like
straight out of photoshop or indesign or
something and
tweaking it all here is always really
nice
it feels better yeah
yeah let's try that that looks cool
all right i'll save this and it should
should
update did it already a little shiny
i'll show you what i have i'll show you
what i like about what i have
um yeah yeah let me switch this over
so i i really like how
the the roughness here is tweaked i mean
it's probably around point two
point three and you can see the grooves
in like the tiling and whatnot
i really enjoy that it's not too shiny
like you're not you're not getting like
really crisp
uh let's see what my settings are um
it's 0.25 metallic going against what we
said
and uh the base roughness is also 0.25
yeah maybe maybe let's try that see what
it looks like 0.25 yeah for metallic and
roughness
and is it still updating the color it
looks like on your end
uh the color it should be why is it not
am i brick shiny yeah
oh because i'm multiplying the base
color against the contrast maybe
what if i take this
no that's not what i want
yeah it should be happening real time
right in the editor there
brick white i don't have that assigned
in here
brick white yep
brick shiny yep
oh here we go
you just didn't save this one or
something yep
that'll do it that will do it indeed
yeah uh using some metallic for like
alien armor and like gems that's a good
idea too
that sounds sweet oh here we go that's
better
yes
yes
someone mentioned uh putting a little
water puddle in the middle of it
to be very interesting we could do that
we could totally do that um
but i feel like if we if we did that
like we would need
grungy oh sir the uh what is it
decals decals you could do something
evolver what's up evolver thanks for the
super chat
appreciate you man this is looking good
have a great weekend you too
you too sir have a good weekend yourself
um
chris was one of the early guys who
helped me out with uh with unreal
um so i appreciate it man
i really do he was there on the
beginning of my unreal journey
yeah i think some some decals could
really
make it look nice like up on the uh the
edges
perhaps or some leakage oh can you do
radial
like radial leakage or is it all linear
so it is let me check i i've only ever
done it linear um
you could also do that in photoshop too
yeah totally yeah so this will show
uh yeah just uh in a cube
super tiny
let's just scale that way up just so we
can see it a little bit
what is that is
a default decal texture oh
i think it's like a like overlaying like
a
concrete tile or something yeah but it's
a little emissive too so it's going to
look kind of blown out
uh what if i hop
into mega scans here
so what are you thinking for for decals
um probably if if we're i don't want to
go too crazy with it you know
um like if we have a thing of water in
the middle i was imagining like rings of
grunge on the outside of that water and
then they'd probably be
on the top edge leaking in but maybe we
could just do
around the outer edge like streaky
leakage
moving down towards the bottom and then
maybe like one or two spots where we
have like
a hole or something or like a
you know some some water damage or
something maybe
yeah so i'm thinking this one will be
good
for at least getting like a mat for um
the puddle so i'll import that
let's try getting some of the
streaky leakage wall rust
gross i love it
maybe some like large uh large scale
leakage
if they have any like stuff that like
spans across a big distance that we
could just wrap it around
or something
i go up to sizes maybe i can do large
this is a pretty big well it doesn't
really like blend at the bottom
does it maybe it does no not really
i can just scale anything up uh how
about
what's a good one like this one
it's so subtle yeah
so i'm trying to think what can i do
here to help out to get us closer
to the final i know that we still need
to place
uh like all of the uh
the the ropes and stuff i don't know
i feel like since the main project is on
your end most of the stuff is happening
on your side
i just don't know what else i can do
here besides you know
art directing here to get this thing
uh closer what about um
[Music]
any like ancillary buildings around here
any
anything you want to change about the
towers no the towers i mean all that
stuff is good
i think we just need to add some ropes
and stuff yeah so
the central column that the ropes are
going to connect to
what are you going to do for that
central column i was going to just
string them up
across this thing so like the ropes
would just kind of be connected
between the towers themselves i guess oh
got it so it'd go like from a to b b to
c c to a
yeah and then like at different levels
that makes sense but that's gonna be
really cool
uh that's gonna like frame it really
well as well
i'm gonna take this change the roughness
to
zero let's see what this looks like oh
man look at that
beautiful water damage oh that's great
so the nice thing about decals is that
since it's a cube it projects
that onto everything within that surface
and as you move it further away
it like blends it in and out so to get
it from
showing on the top of this little nub
we can um set the scale back to
one one one here pow pow pow
and change these values so x is gonna be
like five thousand centimeters nope
try again
there we go dude that's so cool
ah it's so cool yeah i'd scale that up
so it's a little like
a little bigger in the middle there man
that's amazing
that's so sick
and that uh that's so easy to just like
take take what was this originally like
a patch
in concrete or something and suddenly it
just looks like water
uh i'd probably want to like take some
of this roughness out um
sorry the normal but uh because it's
adding roughness basically the normal
right so now there you go oh man i'm
convinced
yeah what does it look like from a
distance
and you're trying to orbit it so that it
catches the sun it might be able to get
yes
oh oh yes oh there it is sun
that's so cool that is so cool
all right let's do the same for some
leakage around here yeah
so obviously the real urcebo
satellite collapsed
and has been since decommissioned so
adding like the deteriorated geometry
that would take some time
but uh adding like this grunginess
that's gonna add so much to it
so let's add some grunginess on the
sides
and then we'll add the cables and then i
think from there we can set up our
camera
and tweak our final light settings and
all that stuff
um i love it and then i'll hop into
photoshop and i'll like
do some final touches
didn't do anything it's very subtle
here you can look at this uh yeah
there you go on the side that's what we
need yeah that's what we need
yes oh man it's so gross i love it
perfect
this just screams decommissioned
satellite dish to me
that's sick dude i love it
so you're thinking just like a couple of
those scattered around here yeah
absolutely
you like widen it out a little bit or
something too
that looks great
oh i love how it like yeah because of
the
the the it's a box right but
it's a spherical object so if we like
lift it out of here we get like some
natural
banding through the middle oh that looks
awesome yeah that's like exactly
what i was trying to do with the texture
that's perfect um
look at that maybe one more here
that's great the decals man that's the
way to go
for sure i'm actually gonna just like
swap this out for
this wall rest just to see how that
looks it's a little
that's great it's just not as
recognizable as uh
as the other two yeah you want to get
the old one instead
oh no no i mean like i like how it was i
like oh how it
yeah because they all kind of look the
same um
because they kind of have that like hard
fall off oh that's great
so i think we can actually go in here
and dip down that color
so over the five years i've been using
unreal i've seen a lot
a lot of fly-throughs and arc viz demos
and tutorials and just like
you know super nice camera panning
through an apartment and
it feels like 90 percent of the time
whenever i see a really fancy lighting
study
in a interior environment it's always
a pristine eastern european
minimal black and white loft apartment i
swear
every single time and i always want
people to add just like a little bit of
grunge because like
seriously who who doesn't have who
amongst us does not have leakage
somewhere in their home right seriously
yeah it's uh it's those surface
imperfections they're so important
yeah you really are um so from here i'd
probably
once you get them placed i'd probably
take them all down by half
they're just a little intense um
and the guy on the left there like they
definitely are
more on the cubic side i don't know if
there's a way to make it more radial
or at least cheat it to make it feel
more radial
yeah um what could we do
we could literally kick it over to
photoshop and just
bend that i could yeah bend it in um
seems like a lot of work it does seem
like a lot of work we could
uh i guess triple the amount of decals
and just like stagger them
uh and just like rotate them in a little
bit well this is this is a really good
look the one that you just added looks
great
like maybe maybe taking that one and
just throwing it on like the clean side
and then we can just bring everything
down by half
yeah super subtle i like it
all right so there should be yep opacity
intensity
here we go here we go 0.5
mm too much
0.8 is probably good and then this rust
is a little bit too much huh the rest is
a little intense yeah
all right oh boy
um i love it for the big one on the
bottom right
i would rotate that yeah i'd rotate that
uh clockwise just so that if you go to a
top view
yeah a little bit more it's got that one
main one that's like
yeah something like that and then scoot
it to the right a little bit
that looks freaking great dude holy crap
looks that looks like that's awesome um
okay so let's let's texture up these uh
these towers real quick yes
so do you have that um as material you
want to transfer over or do you want to
use
uh something else oh you had the noisy
thing it is not really working
um the dirt node thing is not really
working it's going to take a little bit
more time to figure out
um what i have on here is just our just
a basic
material with like very very simple
it's just white with a little bit of
some metallic
and some roughness um
[Music]
just to catch the sun and so they're not
black you know
and i think i want to frame it so that
it's looking towards the sun
so it's we're seeing those really nice
reflections off the
off the dish
and then our our towers will be a little
silhouetted anyway so
it's not going to be the end of the
world if they're not like super detailed
that looks freaking awesome
i love that we can actually see the sun
over there too
yeah that's that's awesome
this is the most inconvenient hotkey
i've ever seen in my life but
if you hold right ctrl right alt
and l at the same time you get this
pop-up gizmo and you can just move the
mouse
it is i've never seen such an
uncomfortable hotkey
before to use in my left hand oh man
that's carpal tunnel
all day right
that's cool though i like that
i've i've been saying this wrong the
whole time this is in fact a telescope
not a satellite um i'm sorry
i was wrong don't say that not to change
the thumbnail in the title of the video
and i have to
change it this is uh um
inspired by it yeah so absolutely there
you go there's your out
[Music]
that looks super good man i love how
grungy that looks
yeah um so yeah i'll just
slap a texture on those towers
let's get some ropes on there and then
let's get our final framing
going all right
here's the same the same
shiny brick we had um
so we didn't unwrap these towers
right okay i can do that real quick
let's see how this goes
antenna we go back up to
uv channel zero maybe box or something
where's that
cylindrical maybe yeah let's generate
uvs
cylindrical would probably be the best
let's try that show gizmo let's hide the
uv
yo alt isn't needed ctrl
l alt isn't needed control
l dude that's not
nearly as challenging control light
that's sick lucas781
shoutouts dude always learning something
always learning something you just saved
me
so much pain in my life control
alt l open bracket
tilde that's the that's what
[Laughter]
why is this if you fit it again it'll
it'll like snap
uh wait weird it should be able to like
stretch to fit
i thought that's what fit was supposed
to do because i'm unworld
what the heck man well let's just let's
just see
can i apply customer and light my pv
what let's do one
oh um this did not import with a
generated
light map evidently so if i go up to
light map coordinate index now
build settings yes okay i'm gonna
build a light map for channel one
now we have two uvs up here
yep channel one channel zero okay okay
so now i can override channel 0
with this one
call it good
whoa that's something
that looks like a rocky road freaking
ice cream right there dude
oh man it really does
wow yeah that's why i just went with
like a
just like a color and a reflectivity as
opposed to anything
crazy
yeah let's see if this one's a little
better
not really but yeah i'll just go color
reflectivity
uh so i'll make another master material
for that m m
towers just do this real quick
uh base color and
did you have specific values for
metallic roughness um yeah what do i
have
um let's see i got
oh it was 0.25 metallic 0.25 roughness
sweet and the base color was just
matched
you know to that brick basically
got it and you can probably
the uvs were the issue but having some
sort of generic
grungy noise or something but
we may not need that
yeah let's let's see oh compiling
shaders there we go i'll let this sit uh
let's do those cables how about that yep
save real quick how are you doing clint
i'm great
yeah i'm excited to see how this thing
uh how this thing looks i wanna
i wanna figure out the lighting here and
maybe get a bit more volumetric
fogginess going you know i love me some
fog
um i think that'll make it look really
nice
and going for that like blue cyan
kind of orange orange teal vibe perhaps
dark blue and orange maybe
overall but we can tweak all that stuff
in photoshop too
yeah totally um
[Music]
end location cables
i had a double what did you learn i had
to double click the end like it's like a
little tiny piece
like do you see it can you pull it out
and zoom it
so you double click the end whoa yeah
i'm just going to hide that
i'm like clicking through it
you should get i think okay there you go
and then you move that
just drag that to the end of location
yeah
got it so that correlates to this xyz
here
and i think you have to get before you
before you place that i think you need
to get the other end
set first got it okay
all right here's how this is going to go
down so i have the
absolute world position of the tower
itself and that pivot is
centered which is awesome i'm going to
take the
cable i'm going to paste that right in
here
and then boom i love that it's
just flapping around like that that's
super cool it's so cool
and then this one actually what is the x
what is the z of this 11 300
exactly so same with this one
world go in here
and location paste
1100
and location paste 11 300
oh i have it i copied the wrong thing
man i was about to feel so smart
copy that's perfect yeah
and location based on 300
what what
okay that's not going to work i'll just
do it the other way
so excited almost
there we go there we go so then the uh
width
of the cable has to be bumped up
chunkage
a number of sides is probably fine um
maybe
more segments so it droops a little bit
more segments okay
where cable length segments
let's try like 50 yeah oh man
oh that's awesome let's do 200.
i have never enjoyed droopy cables
so much in my life before
this is yeah you can just imagine the
sound effects
that'd be so sick um
so i'd probably get i don't know how
dude that's sick
so i'd probably get the trifecta going
with the cable edge
and then i would probably have another
layer of cables
if you duplicate that trifecta um
down about a third so that there's some
lower
cables and then maybe a little bit more
just like a tenth of the way down so
there's like
a lower chunk of cables you know
yeah what what is this
dude that'd be so intense
my god what a what a wacky program
[Laughter]
yeah we should probably take my life
take our cable thickness and i'd match
it to
the thickness of the top little spire
gotcha yeah that makes sense
dude shout outs to the guy who was like
yo use the cables and unreal
yeah seriously
all right so if i select both of these
cable with probably
120 how's that look
yeah maybe 100 yeah
that's nice i think we give them like a
nice reflective
white that way like they catch like the
glint of the sun would be incredible to
really frame up
our uh our satellite this is looking
sick dude
yeah i'm very happy with this yeah same
okay i'm gonna make another material for
that real quick
uh actually nm towers
this is good we have some basic
parameters in here i'll just use that
that might be good just that one
man here we go again
okay so eric is saying that in the cable
attach
end you can select an actor in
the e skin
i think that's a typo to attach it to
there might be an option to like
attach it to something
right um attach end to reference to
actor
okay and then maybe end location would
just be a
value offset of that pivot
oh my oh my gosh uh let's try that
so i'll put this new material on both of
these cables
make this lucas is saying socket name
you'd attach it to a socket
socket name but there's no socket on
these is
the issue
all right it's looking like the
battlefield 3 map is what we got so
that's hey
that's that's not that's all i ever
wanted
all right that catches a little bit of
light i think you have to orbit though
orbit around so that you're facing the
sun
yeah yeah yeah then when we're like here
this ever stops wobbling i can see
some aliasing happening where it is
catching the sun so when that's
done how do you get it to rest to get it
to rest
um yeah let me see if i can mess with
this
yeah if anyone knows uh here you keep
you keep doing your thing i'll do some
research r d on my end and see if i
can't figure out how to get this thing
to rest
um what is it called cable actor yeah
so cool
gabriel thank you i appreciate you
um the super chat is much appreciated
man rock on
keep doing your thing thanks for uh
thanks for joining us
cable length all right so if i
attach end to yeah there's an attach
end to um thing so if i select this
uh this guy and we find it see
zach d um mentioned a way to get rid of
the ghosting with the aliasing
uh using a console command that's
definitely helpful
what i'm hoping to do is use the movie
render queue
to get some super super uh anti-aliasing
um but yeah seeing that in editor would
be
a nice thing to do yo
okay got updates for you
yes so the cable
oh dude this is the way to do it okay
so basically there is a
an option for the cable if you select
your cable
um under the cable options on the right
uh the third option attach
end to drop that down and you can
you can pick your actor so you color
drop it basically you use a little
dropper
choose the basically the structure you
want it to go to with the dropper
like in your viewport and
it'll just stick there and you can move
the
the other end around um
what is going on
yeah and then you just offset it
so like one end will always stay fixed
and actually location
so here i'm gonna switch over yeah yeah
so basically like i have this cable
actor right here
and it's just attached to uh
this this actor so i just color pick it
boom
and the offset i work it so it just goes
up to the top
and wherever i move this guy it's moving
around and i bet you you can probably
just set the segments back to 10 when
you're placing all of these things
you know get everything in place and
then once your cables are in place
there's no jiggle
you can give it like maybe 30 segments
and then it'll it'll rest a little
easier
okay does that make sense oh so so the
attach n2
is the the second pillar
right or is it the first it's the second
one it's the end attach to the end
of it yeah um and then you can just move
like
the other pieces around but it looks
like you already have them placed pretty
easily
um you look like you're pretty much good
to go
you just need to duplicate all all that
stuff and like
move it down so that there's like
another
another tier of of cables if that makes
sense
and you can take your iterations or
sorry you can take your segments back up
to 10
or down to 10 so there's not as much
floppage
segments down to 10.
yeah that just makes them super rigid
which looks awesome
but that'll then you'll sag it from
there so they're not flying all over the
place
oh okay so you're doing that to set it
yeah kind of yeah and then you just drop
it down to like
you know go back to like 100 or
something or not maybe 50.
this is just so cool yeah like that just
that's happening like
realistic physics and weight i'm sure
there are engineers in this chat just
like screaming at their computers right
now but
uh this looks super cool
maybe like 80. i wish it would just like
freeze enable stiffness maybe maybe
that's exactly what i want
it's not dynamic or enable gravity it it
still
is um that's gravity
collision simulate uh
segments here we go
nope use gravity force for droop instead
gravity is enabled by default um
if we go into world settings uh and
where is it uh drop down nope not here
not here
override world gravity
i mean i feel like that's not going to
affect it very much
it's like the the tension and
bounce of it skip update one recently
rendered collision
cable forces cable gravity scale maybe
that's what he's talking about
gravity set on the cable whoa
it will gravity's okay okay here we go
no there's gravity in cable settings
increase it to get droop thank you
thank you who was that brady thank you
what's the what's the move he said uh
in the cable itself there's a cable
forces section
if you up yeah cable gravity scale
that'll help get droop
yeah okay whoa don't set it to 10
don't set it to 10. he said uh yeah
turn that up and keep segments down oh
yeah yeah yeah
okay okay you can set it to 10 if your
segments are set to 10.
oh hey no that totally works segments
set your segments to like 20
and then set your like gravity scale to
50 or something
and that it kind of chills it chills it
out pretty faster it's like it's like
springiness so
nice awesome yeah just like the real
world right you just up the gravity
and keep the segments normal is that how
cables work in the real world that's
awesome
uh okay cool how how does this look clay
that looks
great i would do one more set of cables
your bottom tier
just duplicate that bottom tier one more
time and move it down like
20 feet so they're just like dull it's
like double stacked
not even like blah blah blah blah blah
blah go up towards yeah like there
or something yeah um yeah that
helps that's pretty freaking sweet
yeah man all right
uh how are you feeling about getting
some renders this bad
boy yeah great let's um let's see if we
can't tweak some of the lighting and the
fog
and then and then let's render it out
also shout outs to christian uh for the
super chat
always hitting me up with that kombucha
money i appreciate it
um and what the heck man i think it's
time for kombucha so
steve i'm gonna be back in like
literally 20 seconds
um if you want to mess with some
lighting and some fog i'll uh
yeah bear back
oh he didn't cut we're okay still going
all right uh so let's get a little bit
more
fog here yep yep yep
i never really get the chance to work
with fog
very much this feels good i never cover
i never cut three never cut
0.08 oh all right here we go
this is what we're talking about right
here this is the this is the look
ready ready oh man
that's so cool i gotta like move those
clouds a little bit
that's amazing
we could even just hide the clouds
drop into hdri later if we want um
dude that looks amazing how do you feel
about
uh angle
hmm we can we can change the atmosphere
color too so we can
like exacerbate some of those hues
i think it's actually not bad um
as far as angle goes i would
let's get a let's get a cine like camera
actor in here and let's get it
let's get it some like widescreen some
widescreen vibes going
so we can really get behind a camera and
frame it up with like a
maybe a maybe a 80 mil lens or something
all right let's go for the uh
can we get the snyder cut black bars and
everything oh no no we got to get black
bars
top and bottom son all right
so uh 16.99 hasn't used cinematic camera
actor before
this simulates realistic cameras and
actual
kinds of lenses so uh
focal length what are we thinking eight
try 85
85 pow
and like just freaking go
all right maybe 50.
because it makes it feel large when you
zoom in like that
um yeah it really makes it feel large
now i feel like our
let's let's boom up and try and get
so that we can see the bottom of that
thing like we were before
and let's uh maybe adjust
let's try 35.
and you might need to have the sun like
uh angle up so it hits
the inside of that dish a little bit
more and is there no way
to
oh man so freaking cool
no way to what i think here
i think regardless we want the sun
pointing at the camera basically
so that it's reflecting off that dish um
wherever we're lining up our camera too
can you maybe get
our camera this is so hard to describe
this as opposed to just doing it this is
funny
um get your camera so that both of those
towers on the left and right
are like equidistant and symmetrical
that makes sense okay so if you like
orbit counter-clockwise
oh i see what you mean so it's like
this
right yeah and then maybe just go a
little off from here
so like back towards the other side so
we're not losing the
foliage yeah a little bit more a little
bit more
is this the right aspect ratio is this
16 9
it is it's just the size of the viewport
well
maybe it's not um
yeah it is 69. can you do uh 235
perhaps is it one of these i don't know
let me see um let me try and
pull out a camera actor
uh is it two to three point five is that
a minor yeah let's try that two three
five
try that one
oh gosh
there's no way to if we scale
this dish
so it's a bit more shallow
i feel like that's what we want to do we
want to scale the dish so it's a bit
more shallow
yeah so we can see into it a little bit
more at a
lower angle you know what i mean
so we get yeah some more of the like
atmosphere yeah i'd even go lower
like that that might be nice actually
something like that
yeah okay that's pretty sweet
and then we'd want to be orbit the sun
so that it's pointing to the camera so
we're getting those
nice like reflective highlights off
the back end
and that is hard to do
here we go
clouds are you just getting in the way
here we go
like yeah like that something like that
with a bit more fog
so that the background kind of goes off
into the into the
uh into the background i guess
i'm gonna make this not cast with the
clouds
there we go so we get a little bit more
even i don't have to worry about
yeah moving the clouds themselves uh
and then you said more fog
mess with the fall off a little bit less
height start distance
boy here we go
direction light
so the source angle if no one has messed
with this before
this determines how much diffusion there
is with the sun
coming through the atmosphere itself so
if
we have a lot of fog we probably want
this to be pretty dang high and that's
going to like
diffuse out some of those shadows
but maybe having like some more
definition would be nice too
yeah maybe like that
that's pretty freaking cool i think what
we can do here is like
go for a series of shots and oh you can
kick them out to me and i'll
i'll like tweak them in photoshop if we
want to do like three or four or
something
um yeah that feels fun to me i think
it's just the sky
it just kind of goes off to like a gray
background um
so i don't know if we can like push the
the landscape further back or
just adjust the camera so that we're not
seeing that up there
you know what i mean yeah maybe like
you're right it does kind of just like
get lost
one thing we could do actually um some
of the
landscape packs i imported actually had
some giant
meshes to use in the background
oh wonderful
yeah it's perfect maybe not snow caps in
puerto rico
but uh we could do something like this
way better yeah i don't even care that
there probably aren't mountainous yeah
that's a snow cap
it looks so cool um
is there a way to tweak the lighting a
little bit so that we catch more
of the glint off of the wires
um uh let's take a look at the wires
themselves maybe
it would be something we can do with
like the amount of sides they have
[Music]
change the sides to three
so the roughness to zero maybe that'll
help
it helps a little bit but they still get
lost
especially trying to orbit the sun a
little bit and see what's like the sweet
spot
oh dude
that looks so cool
there's just so much so many good
options no
what if i crank that
oh
my goodness
i think there we go i think we just need
god that looks so cool
i think i'm very happy with that we just
need um
here how about that if you're happy with
that render that out
send it to me and i will
i will start photoshopping on my end and
then pick like two or three more angles
that you like
that are a little different maybe like
go to 100 millimeter lens zoom in
try and go for that nasa shot that you
showed me the other day
and then maybe do like a top-down
satellite view
um and like feel free to adjust the
light to get some nice
long stretchy shadows for that one or
something you know yeah
definitely all right i'm going to fly
through this real quick i'm going to
make
a quick sequencer setup so we can output
a
really nice high quality
uh render here
so sequencer is what you would use to
output like a nice animated video
i'm just gonna select our camera and we
only really want like
a couple frames um
just so we get like a couple different
samples to choose from
and then in here gonna save that and
minimize it because we don't need it
anymore
before you render also is there is there
uh like spherical reflection captures or
forced leds to zero that kind of stuff
to make it look as nice
as possible um i also feel like the
shadows underneath
the the radar dish they're blue and like
lit up i feel like they would be darker
you know what i mean darker yeah uh
that would be something we can tweak in
the skylight
so right now we just have uh one
intensity scale if we do like point
five one then we're losing it on the
side of the dish itself
that feels a little better
but yeah this guy atmosphere itself a
little blue
is it volumetric is that what we need do
we need to like go for a uh
i remember seeing some setting where
like someone clicked volume metric
something underneath in the fog like
took it off from that like bluish and it
just made it feel a lot more natural or
something
yeah uh
dude that's insane that's insane how
good that looks though
albedo
scattering distribution
extinction scale
why is my volumetric fog not doing
anything it's because it's so
far from the distance maybe one guy's
saying volumetric shadows are not
available with ray tracing
good to know i did not know that thank
you for the
tip that's a
definitely good tip uh i'll get into
that render real quick though so we can
hop right into it so uh with that set up
in a sequence
uh if we go up to where is it um
window i thought it was just right here
there should be a uh
render option i'll just kick it out
out as is we can just roll with that for
now
shape review all right here we go uh
okay how are you screenshot how do you
want to send this to me you want to
email it i can switch to my screens so
you can email it without having your
stuff seen
sure yeah let's do it i'm gonna switch
to me right now
um sweet yeah so let me know once you
email it over
and then i'll i'll like switch to our
interview screen or something so i can
pull this up into photoshop
i'm actually going to close unreal
on my end here and let's open up
photoshop because
guys a lot of uh a lot of the
i mean you saw how far we can get that
is in unreal
okay cool yeah you guys saw how far we
can get in unreal
um which is very very far but there is
still
an extra level of something we need to
do to make it look
a little bit more realistic so that's
gonna be open up
opening up photoshop and like tweaking
uh
basically making it look like it was
shot from a camera versus rendered from
a program and i'm gonna show you guys my
process on how to do that it's very
simple
very subtle but it's very important you
can go overboard very easily
um but it's very necessary so let me let
me just pull up steve's
email here and he'll be sending me like
two more
um we can get three different looks or
something
so let's someone a couple of people
mentioned
uh post process volumes we could use
that for color correction color grading
as well
but even then you'll still want to use
photoshop to
get that extra level at the end as well
absolutely
all right so i have the first one here
let's open it up in photoshop
um did i desktop it i did
all right
very nice okay
so let me see if i can't move our heads
around a little bit
so you guys can get a better view of
this thing um
get me up in here
okay so the first thing i'm going to do
is probably work the tones in
adobe camera raw all right so let's
right click it and i'm going to
convert to smart object that way all the
stuff we do will not be destructive so
i'm gonna hit
ctrl shift a and that brings us into
adobe camera raw
um let's get our heads on the other side
now all right guys bear with me
cool so what i like to do here is
i'm a sucker for vignetting so let's see
if i can't
zoom out just a little bit more maybe 50
yeah so we can see the whole thing
let's scroll down until we see
the optics option and we'll crunch that
vignette
get it going just a little bit and i
like to bring my midpoint
and just the hair
and we might actually be able to do the
vignette with a bit more control let me
show you that let me show you how i'm
going to
get a little bit more control over this
um
i could use what's called called a
radial filter
and i'll just basically select
you know this box here holding space bar
will allow you to move the whole thing
and we'll take that and if i drop the
exposure you can see
we're getting that that vignette effect
and you can adjust the feathering up
here as well
and maybe the
we scale it up a little bit
something like that and i want to bring
the shadows down
but i want to do it over the entire
image so we'll go back to the little
edit
option up here these little lines with
this with the circles on them
let's crank the shadows down let's maybe
oh steve maybe get some bloom going in
your next one
oh man so much bloom let's see
maybe we can take the
we don't want to dehaze it certainly
don't want to dehaze it and adding
clarity kind of
i don't know gets you a
maybe a little bit that could help out
and i might even be able to sharpen this
too just a touch
where would uh effects perhaps
grain so we could i'm gonna add green
later
not in camera raw though where would oh
here's my sharpening
just a little bit of sharpening can help
out
um
let's maybe up the contrast
drop the exposure a little bit bring up
the whites
yeah i think some sort of bloom could
look really nice in the next version
oh yeah
where do you stand on lens flares clint
um
they can easily be overdone
yeah that's what i think too yeah
and let's adjust the let's give this
some color
so color correction is when you're
trying to match and
fix you're trying to correct the color
of an image
with the tones the values the highlights
and all that stuff the shadows
color um grading
color grading is when you give it a
style
so let's see if we can't give this like
a little bit of style here
i could easily save this and have this
be a pass and i might just do that
right so this is the before and the
after on the image here
and i want to bring in some of the blue
tones in the shadows
so i think what we could do is perhaps
and also you'll notice because it is a
smart object i right clicked and
set it to smart object it sets the
color correction we just did as like a
little checkbox that we can turn on and
off
which is very handy we can go back in
and continue tweaking those settings and
stuff
i wonder if i add a new one if it'll go
back into the original
or if it'll make a new one so i hit
control shift a
and there's a new layer on top i like
that so
let's go back out to 50 and try and get
some of those blue
tones in the shadows so the temperature
maybe we could just slide to a bluish
but i don't
really like that i really specifically
want to just work with the shadows so
we can just take the shadow slider go to
a blue and crank the saturation
and get a little something out of those
shadows there
that's not bad not bad
at all
we could distort the image a little bit
that's probably a little
a little heavy let's just hit okay
and so we have a whoa that's crazy what
on earth is happening
i've never seen that before what did i
leave distortion on
hold on
is going on
oh my goodness
distortion is set to zero what the heck
uh let's maybe just
delete that one
dude that jacked up everything
whoa
uh
let's just undo a few times here
what the heck
uh
i have no idea what i did guys that is
that is weird i've never seen that one
before maybe i'll
save
and reopen
psd
that was weird
oh we got some nice bloom going on here
oh that's awesome you guys are going to
see i'll let it be a surprise
i open i open premiere come on photoshop
nice if you want to email me
that when you get a chance headed your
way
wow totally destroyed the whole thing
that is
crazy what what
all right you should have those now okay
and then um
maybe do like a a top-down
shot like a super cool top-down shot
with like long shadows with volume
metrics that could be super cool
all right y'all i'm just gonna give this
another shot here because that
was janky
let me do this really quick so we're
going to convert to a smart object a
little bit a little bit of review
ctrl shift a gets us into adobe camera
raw where we can tweak some settings
here
let's uh give it that radial filter
let's go to 50 so we can see everything
we'll give it like a nice
wide radial filter there we'll drop the
exposure
um maybe make the shadows a bit darker
lift the blacks maybe just a little bit
kind of get a filmic look on it and then
let's go back to the main tweaking
where we can adjust the contrast
a little bit uh perhaps get some of the
some sharpening in here um
[Music]
and it did look like a vignette glitch
it's what it looked like
yeah steve go for like a a nice like
sunset
shot or something with those like super
stretched shadows
oh yeah like blue and orange vibes you
know
[Music]
same for top down yeah
um this is not bad here
let's go ahead and say okay on this
maybe the vignette is a little intense
so let's just adjust that a little bit
dude what it's doing it again
why
is it my radio this this filter
wow that's crazy
so there is another way we can do it
it's just being janky we'll hit ok
and i mean i just have
basically like a vfx overlay
that is a vignette that i can use
and we'll drop this in yeah this guy
right here
bam
perfect and if you just set that to
overlay
and drop the opacity a little bit
and get a little something now from here
what i what i do all the time is add
film grain
film grain really takes it to the next
level um
it makes it so it doesn't feel so sharp
and cold
it actually adds a little bit of
softness to your image which is kind of
what you want you don't want it to feel
like it just
came right out of a cg program so
let's go ahead and zoom out and just
position this up however we want
set the overlay that's the setting there
and if we go to a hundred percent
you can see on and off gets you
some nice nice grain
there and just gets you texture
right in your image which is very handy
now the image is also a little too sharp
so i'm gonna add some
blur to it as well
um so i'm wondering can i do this so
it's non-destructive i'm gonna duplicate
it ctrl j
just in case so we have like a backup
version down here
and then let's go ahead and go to filter
blur and gaussian blur
just try
1.5 maybe
and great it adds it as a smart layer
which is perfect
1.5 is too much
so i want to take that to
0.5
looking pretty sweet we could if we
wanted to actually
this might help us um let's go back into
the camera raw settings here and
i want to brighten up this center dish
right here it's a little in like the
mid-tone area
so let's go to 50 and let's try this
radial filter again and i just want to
select the area that is this radar dish
like right up in here pretty close there
and i want to lift it so i'll just boost
it oh god
why
that's so weird is it because the image
is
whoa that's weird it's 8-bit
it's rgb why is it doing that
well alternatively what we could do is
duplicate this layer
and we'll click this little button here
this is like the adjustment mask button
the add layer mask let's click that and
it makes this little window here on the
right
if we invert it ctrl i it'll turn it off
control i invert sets it to white turns
it back on
but what we want to do since it's the
same image let's go ahead
and let's rasterize it so we'll right
click the image
rasterize the layer and if we
were to just hit i don't know um
actually no we don't need to raster it
let's hit ctrl l
for levels and just push this up
maybe the gamma we push the gamma push
the brightness
a little bit
now the whole image is brighter if we go
to that adjustment mask that we made
the layer mask hit ctrl i it turns it to
black you guys see that
it turns it off so knowing that we can
select this little black window here
and paint white onto that image there
to brighten up little areas of this
thing here
it should be really helpful for bringing
out certain parts of the image
and that might be a little intense
depending
so you can go over it with like a gray
brush
or just take the opacity down of the
whole thing so you can kind of lift that
up a little bit
and you might even be able to get some
nice uh
like a gradient on it so if i were to
take a large let's see
let's take a large
black brush use the brackets to open it
up a little larger
right click make sure your hardness is
set to zero
and we can kind of paint in so it just
gets brighter uh
on the right side and on the left side
it's
back to how it was and that gives us a
little bit of
make this brush even bigger
we have like a nice little gradient
going over this thing
and it gives us a little bit more depth
out of that
that feels pretty cool let's check the
ratio here if we do if we want to go
really intense you could do uh
let's do pixel with height resolution
we'll do
1920 by 810 oh
super high-res dude so so widescreen
the uh the image i gave you two was kind
of
uh big as well that's totally cool by
8 10.
so this is like your
your super wide screen
if you want to if you want to go super
widescreen with it
but framing wise
i feel like we would need this area to
be a little smaller and just have more
on the left and right
we don't really have but that's totally
fine
no i don't want that
this is cool i'm gonna save this um is
there anything else i want to do to this
we could potentially oh
dude black and white looks really cool
i'm not gonna lie there's a
three more renders sitting in your inbox
too if you want to try with one of those
too
yeah yeah let me switch back over to the
interview
section i'll pull these emails up
uh if you want to jump to me i can
yeah i'm on you got another one too okay
just doing one last render here i was
thinking just because uh
we have this nice light maybe i could
get some occlusion from that tower
ah that seems good so i enabled uh this
plugin called
um hi-res movie render queue something
like that
uh i'm butchering the name i know and if
we go to cinematics we now have movie
render queue and what this lets us do
is output um
from sequencer with crazy high
settings so i'm going to try kicking out
uh
png and then we can add anti-aliasing
and this is going to be
let's say eight counts spatial eight for
temporal
uh override our initial settings and we
can actually
this is the craziest thing to me we can
output as large as like
16k video from unreal with this plug-in
with crazy aliasing png 8-bit 16-bit
whatever
and then it actually renders each image
as tiles
that get automatically stitched together
so
i'm just going to keep it reasonable and
just do
let's say 3840 by 2160 no tiling
but some really nice aliasing we don't
need to warm up frames or anything
[Music]
we could add like a burn-in if we wanted
console commands it should automatically
take care of lods so i'm not worried
about that let's see if this
cuts out my stream if i render hopefully
no issues
i get a nice preview window maybe i can
put that on the other screen
did i drop no sorry i was i was zoning
in what happened
uh i'm rendering it's it's on my second
screen right now i can't
put it on my first but um i get a nice
preview window and it shows frame by
frame everything that's happening and
going through all the sample counts
so i should be able to give you a really
awesome shot
with uh really cool aliasing settings
here in a minute sweet all right i'm
just tweaking
your other renders here
very nice 16k
is simply too many pixels yes this
is true absolutely what's up sodomonte
what happened you couldn't
oh you yeah you're busy that makes sense
uh good to see you
he is the original moderator on the
server awesome awesome and we got
mr darren winkle mr dinklewinkle up in
here as well
another one of the original mods
yeah we're just kind of going over like
settings here
where kicking out final renders and
tweaking them in photoshop here
i hope i'm still here because my gpu
just crashed yeah you're good
okay cool uh yeah so that render didn't
so much work out but
um hey you got some images
i think the last thing i want to try is
one more top down shot
um where it's like
actually when you get to a point are you
at a point where you can kick out one
more
uh give me like 30 seconds cool
dude that's so sick man i love the fog
settings
they're absolutely beautiful
boom that's looking awesome get some
smart filters going if you alt drag your
smart
filters you they'll apply to like the
latest render
and with black and white shots like i
really like to crank
the the contrast
so if i go back into the camera raw
filter for this shot
let's say for instance um
and i take maybe
the clarity up this is kind of like that
hdr effect
you guys might see let's go to 50 and it
kind of gets those mid tones and brings
them out
that's what i want with this and maybe
we could
yeah adjust the shadows the contrast a
little bit
bring the white points up
get real saturated and dark with the
black points and it the black or the the
color version doesn't look
too good with these settings but when i
think when you switch on the black and
white it really
takes it to the next level and another
thing we can do here is
let's give it a
let's see control l for levels
we'll crank it
and we only want those levels to be
basically doing a thing let's see what's
the best way to do this
someone said you can see the edge of the
skybox we're actually not
using a skybox for this uh maybe the
edge of the
background mesh is kind of peeking out
busted no skybox
boom oh maybe it's the horizon is kind
of what we're seeing there
let's see control i yeah gets rid of
that and then i just want to do like a
soft brush soft white brush
to just get a little bit
that's super cool
that is awesome
now this is obviously too intense i
think i need to bring down the opacity
of that so like kind of desaturate it a
little bit
and probably chill out those tones if
it's going to be a color image i'd
probably lift the blacks a little bit
but if it's black and white i really
like it crunched
like that i love that um
what else steve are you think you're at
a point where we can do
a top-down shot together uh
i i just opened another project so i
could migrate something in here so give
me
just a minute sounds good all that loads
let's see this one
i don't know why i hope you're not
offended that i'm making these black and
white
clint i put so much time into that color
oh
literally minutes did you see how many
shaders i had to compile for you oh my
god
uh no it's all good come all the way
over yeah you can cut to me whenever
you'd like
okay yeah um so
here's what i'm imagining for the top
down like just like
go go straight above it look straight
down 90 degrees
um yeah and then let's go with like a
like a 100 mil lens or like maybe even
200 mil something crazy
sick and then yeah blast off
um all right so come down on it yeah
let's rotate the camera
um so that the bottom point of the
triangle is not right at the bottom
center of the screen
oh i see yeah like that
and then you can just have like zoom out
a little bit more
yeah like like maybe there's but the
difference halfway between that
keep coming keep coming oh touchy
coming keep coming
yeah like okay there
[Music]
and then try and and work the sun
so that you get some really intense
lateral shadows
okay so if anyone knows the setting i
need it's something to do with cascaded
shadow maps just the distance that we
have
like getting those to actually cast i
thought it was just
cascade shadow map distance maybe it's a
ray tracing issue
number now like the look that i'm seeing
in my head is like
our shot volumetric volumetric light
volumetric shadows basically it's like
the shadow of this
giant radar dish being cast over the
tops of the trees
um like at a real like hazy kind of
creamy look
does that make sense yeah for sure
and it might actually be nice to lower
the volumetric height fog so it's
peaking out
of parts of the trees but not in in the
others you know what i mean
directional volumetric fog
distance and exponential fog so we got
two things we got rate is
is array tracing enabled on the
directional light
and then volumetric fog distance
in exponential fog
um one guy says try turning off ray
trace light in the directional light
turning off ray choice uh well it's
either
dynamic and ray tracing or well they're
just like a simple ray trace
cast ray tracing shadows wait is ran up
in here
did i hear ren someone said ren
it doesn't look like it though
someone says you have to disable ray
tracing for that to work
okay so maybe just in a ray tracing
version of this project
i just have to well if i disable ray
tracing on the whole project it's going
to take
a long time for those shaders maybe not
the moon but if i could just
we could try just like getting the
camera closer and get those shadows to
come back in
yeah maybe punch out to like a 100 as
opposed to a 200 or something
someone says increase shadow distance
fields
i don't know if any of this stuff is
right i'm just reading
read the chat yeah these are all really
helpful
distance yeah my dynamic shadow
distance is
crazy high and it's not really affecting
anything so i wonder if that's not
actually working with one max draw
distance
let's see if i can just get something
i'm not getting any cascaded shadows
man that's so cool dude yeah looks like
mars coming off the side of that thing
uh another cool thing we can do though
that i did want to show um and someone
actually mentioned this in the chat as
well
we could add things like birds
flying in the air oh and uh that helps
to give
scale oh yeah dude that's a great idea
let's get some burbs up in here spawn
right one i'm just gonna scale up
those these are going to look like giant
birds maybe that's not
the right move wait how'd you get those
birds so quick where did those come from
i migrated these in from another project
i didn't make these originally i think
they're from
some free unreal project but it's
actually part of a particle system
so if i open this blueprint um you can
see there's logic for like
how they spawn how they move uh voids
thing
the whole like what all that stuff like
we had we had to look into that
for uh oh yeah for the birdemic thing it
was like uh a particle system that's
very specific on how birds move and
react to each other and stuff
yeah so if we get close enough we should
see
yep birds dude that is awesome
so maybe we honestly it might be like
better for um the aliasing and quality
if it's just like
shopped in but i love adding birds
whenever i can yeah because everyone's
like whoa you modeled and animated birds
just for this render of this
telescope i was like no man i found
birds
it just had so much having uh something
in the scene to add some depth
yeah so let's get like some like you're
saying casting
over the ground
and then you're saying have the fog like
in the trees but not
like above the trees yeah
yeah that could be really cool
dang i feel like it'd be so cool if
photoshop could add a bloom
slider yeah how do you typically add
bloom
in photoshop you could paint it
by hand um
[Music]
you could also crank the the d haze you
can like
work that a little bit um but
yeah i usually do it in octane that's my
my go-to
sweet oh man here we go that's cool
that's super cool
i love the orange is happening here from
the sun
it's not even in frame but we're getting
like all this cool
splash of color down here
and trues thank you for the super chat
um
he's liking it he says it looks awesome
very happy with all this work i'm i'm
loving this man it looks so cool
yeah i'm so happy with how this is
looking
so sick i got a few different edits
oh my god that looks awesome
yeah you see what i'm saying though
about underneath like i feel like it
wouldn't be as
unless the light has has a direct
view to underneath that thing right it
shouldn't be
like orange like that you know
yeah i saw it in some tutorials someone
checked a box and it like cleaned all
that stuff up i just forget
what it was man like like you were
saying just like
relationships just gotta find the right
checkbox
make everything better
we could
volumetric scattering
i love that it looks like a just like a
light like you get
in the side of the lens there yeah a
little bit
see if i disable that it's not changing
it it could be
it's probably in that atmosphere fog
i'm gonna bounce out our renders here
exponential distribution
it's all about just tweaking values yeah
yep just messing with it until it looks
right
height fog contribution so that's
doing something but it's getting rid of
all the fog i don't want that
and this is also where reference comes
in handy too
feels like oh for sure yeah we're just
kind of like guessing at what it would
look like um
but with reference you could really
lock in a look you have something to go
off of
but yeah we could easily take a whole
another day tweaking from here you know
just to two days even that's the fun
part
it really is yeah it really is
is the dish set to movable it is now
makes no difference though we're
doing completely dynamic lighting
there's no baked lights
up the cloud resolution
that's a good idea
please increase the length of the wires
remove the material right now and look
at the uvs the wires are stretched to
infinity
will look better in final render
there's a million things we could do oh
for sure
oh for sure
all right so make sure this is actually
in
focus if we just select the eyedropper
tool we can do that
so it should be good
right i'm auto exposing let me adjust
that
all right i have everything basically
tweaked
um and as soon as you drop this last
image
i can tweak it and we'll take a look at
everything and then we'll
talk about this art that you guys have
done over this last week
got some winners to announce and uh
oscar i appreciate the super chat thank
you so much
one day i'll visit sweden i think it'd
be an awesome uh an awesome trip
very fun but yeah i appreciate you man
very much
how you looking steve i'm kicking out
the last one
right now cool
all right i'm gonna go to my display
here so you can email that over
all right look at that i only crashed
once today
this is a great day it happens though
it happens all the time yep gpu errors
are the spice of life
so i'll pull open purif here and i'll
drop all of our images into it so we can
get the final look of everything um
let me make sure my email just doesn't
get pulled up here
and sent sweet yeah let me grab these
emails for y'all
grab these pictures i've been
standing this whole time i'm gonna kick
this cat out
oh man rough dude i've been there that
is some
intense unreal just
i'm sweating a little bit
this has been really fun really that'd
be weird just from standing there you
know you never know
breathing heavily as i dial in some
lights
there you go okay all right let's save
this guy guitar jams
thank you for the super chat i see you
thank you so much
um just appreciate you guys sharing your
process and creating fun challenges
absolutely heck yeah man hope you're
learning something
um all right let me let me grab this
stuff here and see what we can
drop in for y'all um
is my microphone still working yeah
mm-hmm okay
all right so i'm gonna chill on this
screen for a
second wait how do i unlock
my pure f control r there we go
chance i appreciate your insight into
the cables i'm for sure gonna like
go back through the stream later and
just read all the comments
um i gotta say i i haven't
streamed before and um
i am in the discord community but i
don't post much i just kind of
hop on every once in a while but
everyone's just so nice
it's true like everyone is so helpful
and crazy talented it's like
it's insane man yeah it's very cool it's
been a really
really awesome community that we've
built and uh
everyone's freaking everyone's
incredible everyone's absolutely
incredible
so we got some really cool shots to show
you guys um these are just different
versions of everything
um and my god they look incredible
i freaking love them so much like
this could straight up be a real a real
photo
and that gets me really excited because
that's what i'm like trying to do and
unreal you know
are you still there steve yep i'm still
here this is
looking so good oh man yeah
i like the black and white uh
especially that middle one there with
the uh yeah less contrast
oh man i love that yeah absolutely
absolutely beautiful
totally is legit i love this one too
this one feels good i'm a sucker for
contrast in black and white
but let's take a look at the color ones
like that is freaking awesome
super cool
so here's a question for the chat if
these were submissions for the weekly
contest
which would you say wins oh clint is
going to win all of them
so one through six
uh we line them up like this
let's do one two three
four five six so the bottom row is four
five six
top row is one two three
what's your guys's favorite five and six
three three people are loving three
three really okay six i was
i i definitely i'm thinking six six and
two for me maybe
yeah man just going
crazy in there yeah um
i really like the bloom effect so i was
using convolution bloom for number four
which is a newish feature really
performance heavy but
it helps simulate like realistic bloom
on like cars
that you get in like product photography
and that looks super cool with like the
color fringing
but yeah no one likes four evidently
that's funny three turned out
i was proud of that like the detail and
like the side of the
the paneling i think looks really nice
um
yeah i think six for me uh
two and six and
tough one i like one and three ooh
number seven yes agreed absolutely
the hidden one but yeah that
dude i'm super proud of this like i feel
like i could just tweak
that lighting all day long and just like
endless options it's so much fun
yeah yeah between the directional light
and the sky atmosphere that's like
realistically creating sunsets and using
like dynamic clouds and stuff
there's literally endless possibilities
for what we could make here yeah
i dig one too yeah i like one this feels
like an actual photo
i mean they all do but this one i don't
know the way this one's framed i really
like this one a lot
all right well i think that's it for the
lesson here
i think we this is this is super cool
i'm very excited with this i'm very
excited with how this turned out
um so i think we are at the point now
where we are going to review the weekly
challenge winners we're gonna do it
together we're gonna talk about the
things we like about it
there's five winners and then there's a
number of
honorable mentions that i just want to
throw out that we can give our
our two cents on so let me see here let
me go to studio mode to make sure
the the winners aren't already popped up
here nope we're good let's switch over
all right so i switched it up a little
bit so it looks like i'm looking at the
art
we're on the top right now um
so guys the challenge this week was
what was the challenge this week it was
uh negative space
oh yeah yeah so everyone had to you know
google what negative space was
and figure it out and make a cool render
uh utilizing negative space and there's
a there's a couple different definitions
there's the idea of like
you know basically having your subject
be on the far right or the far left
frame and then there's like a
a big empty space or negative space left
where it's just a background or a wall
or something but it also it should
tell a story and it should evoke an
emotion
um and then there's the other idea where
like a lot of you guys messed around
with black and white and silhouettes and
stuff
and you kind of it's like a window
within a window or it's like two
positive shapes
fill up a negative space and make it
feel like a different
you know like a different image and
there's examples that i'm about to show
you guys but
let's jump into our winners all right
guys um first off
we have
see we have boom red of paw
is our first winner with this really
cool video
heavily inspired by what's his name
fonho is that his name the photographer
um hopefully i'm not butchering that i
believe
fonho is his name
he is a black and white film
photographer
in hong kong i believe and
man does some really incredible stuff if
you guys don't know this guy
look him up yeah so red of paw
congratulations
for winning the weekly challenge this
week with this awesome video
uh it's very well done your composition
is great it's like the brightest point
is right down the middle with the sky
and it kind of falls off and it's very
easy to look at and there's a lot of
detail going on
um steve you have any anything to add on
this one
um i love
the the depth that we get here like it's
not
as the camera pans forward uh we're not
getting like a uniform
movement there's parallax there's the
things draping in the foreground the
particles are a really nice touch
whenever i see particles in a black and
white video like this usually it's like
way overdone but this is like this is
like the chef's kiss just like
perfect amount uh i am curious
uh are the people like mixamo and cinema
4d
i'd love to hear your approach on that
um yeah totally feel free to just like
shoot me a message or something like i'd
love to
hear more about your process here this
is really cool he's in here he's in the
chat
also he's saying there's sound yeah i
turned it off purposely because i don't
know if it's licensed or not licensed
i'll get the video pulled for that
or um monetization will get cut off
if you can tell me it's uh royalty free
or if you made the song
or what i just don't want to get the
video pulled for that you know what i
mean
so that's why i'm not doing the sound um
unless he says it's fine and then i'll
turn it up for for a pass or something
but
it's royalty free all right nice so let
me
uh yeah i i do like too i just want to
add like
i can't tell what the setting is
i think that's like i don't know if that
was intentional or not but i can't tell
if this is like
modern i'm getting kind of like a
industrial
revolution kind of vibe like maybe like
london but maybe
do i see like those signs are like
chinese or japanese or something i have
no idea it's just super cool
i mean if it's if this is to me is
heavily based off of the photographer
and he he it's he's a you know chinese
photographer around that time 1950s yeah
so it kind of has that vibe to it um
yeah i really
i really dig this one a lot very very
nice
nice job man yeah absolutely all right
guys so
moving on to the next winner here
let's see
who is it who's it gonna be who's it
gonna be
bam sir roger bob congratulations for
winning
this week's weekly challenge with this
awesome image man i love your render
quality
it's very well done i love your colors
very very cool
your character is framed very small in
frame and you have
all this negative space around this
character um
you know kind of giving you the emotion
of it's a very vast very big
place that the character's in um
i really really like it i like your
surface imperfections on the ground
really cool really cool lighting um it
kind of reminds me of uh
i know it's not the same kind of scene
but in the new blade runner
there's a scene where it's like this
orange and yellow room
it's like a little check-in room or
something and it has that
feeling to me i don't know if you
remember the scene i'm talking about
yeah yeah i'm definitely getting that
vibe
and uh i love the use of contrast here
and uh rather than like using negative
space and just making everything
dark except for the thing you want
people to look at
um it's just composed very well
yeah yeah agreed i'm a big fan of it
and just all the details and the
texturing and stuff is cool and i don't
know like if you used
this uh i don't know what you referenced
for this but
it's a really cool space and you should
be very proud so sir roger bob
congratulations
you got the challenge winner role this
week on the discord server
um enter the challenge next week and
hang on to that role
else someone's gonna take it from you
but for this week you got it
it is yours sir um
all right moving on to number
three um all right let's do
boom and boom
uh this is visual
um what an incredible incredible render
i'm such a huge fan of this one it's
very simple but it is so well lit
i love all the detail that you caught in
that picture frame with your top light
and your characters hidden in a really
nice way it's like i want to know more
um i like how simple it is i love all
the negative space in this image
steve do you have anything on this one
yeah
it would have been really easy visual
for you to just like
have a flat wall and like a flat picture
frame or something
but i'm really drawn to all of the
detail that you have here like even even
just that like you know
you took the time to put a nice material
on the background and it like
meshes well with what we see in the
foreground in the mid ground
like the the use of color is really nice
it's very calm and um the contrast top
to bottom
feels really good absolutely and you
have like the uh
the opposite color situation going on
with the green and the pink
which technically is red and green or
color opposites but you're very close
with the pink and the green
um so that's a nice nice little touch
there
um maybe motion blur i don't know motion
blur on the person
that could be interesting if it's like
cranked
i don't know i don't know if he tried
messing with that but i love it the way
it is man i think it's awesome
visual congrats man um
you deserve it you freaking deserve it
man
so you're getting the challenge winner
roll this week and we're moving on to
number four this isn't no particular
order guys it's just uh
just the top five all right
we got boom
the game factory the game factory
coming in as the fourth winner
this week um absolutely beautiful i love
your setup
i love your scene i think you put a lot
of good work into it
uh obviously i'm a huge fan of ghost of
tsushima
so you know this vibe speaks to me a lot
i like your framing you got some
interesting stuff going on
on the right side obviously with your
character but on the left side it's like
man i wouldn't want to be out there and
be rough it'd be a rough one
steve you got anything to add to this
one man yeah um
the motion blur is nice on the snow it's
really subtle but it's definitely there
um again the the common thing i see for
negative space is like an image that's
mostly black but you took it the other
way and
um my eye is drawn to the character
who's
shrouded and uh mysterious so nice job
there i like
i like how he is in like that right
like small portion of the screen and the
left is mostly open
but it's still very balanced that's
that's really nice touch
the perspective is nice too yeah like it
if you laid the
golden ratio um lines over top of this
it might match up a little bit like you
get that big swoop on the left side
coming over
with all the detail on the right like
top right
quadrant with the stairs top left corner
of the stairs
right that focal point but really it's
the character is what you're looking at
in that huge vast space i think it's
super cool so
the game factory congratulations you got
the challenge winner roll
this week hang on to it alright hang on
to it cause they only got it for a week
unless someone else uh
swoops in next week with another win but
you got it this week congratulations
and finally guys moving on to the last
winner
of the weekly challenge excuse me and
then we'll get into some honorable
mentions as we usually do
um but the final winner for this week
is ohm
nico loretta nicola
retta i don't know where the space is on
that but i love this one man
um this was a tough one it was a it was
a toss-up between this one and a couple
others
but i i went with this because i mean
steve really liked this one too
we were talking about how it's very
simple but the motion is implied
in this image here it's a very cool
phone background that i would love to
have on my phone
but it's a great great use of negative
space here you know
you're telling a story with what's going
on your render quality is perfect your
lighting is perfect and i think
it's a really solid simple image that
takes advantage of the negative space
yeah again i love that it's bright
uh the use of color is awesome i can
really like
mentally visualize exactly what's
happening with the motion
there's zero motion blur it looks like
uh and nothing to like
show that there is motion happening but
just like the pose and the way
it's uh composed is just so
so nice i really like it it's very
joyful too
it it feels really good yeah it's cool
to like
it's a really cool idea to take the
character out of it um
yeah yeah you didn't have to do that i
could like you could have easily just
had a character
in the air with a skateboard and it
would have been fine
but i think this i don't know just the
way you did it here without the
character is really cool
so congratulations nico loretta
i'm probably butchering your name
apologies but congratulations on winning
this week's weekly challenge
keep it up man i think that's your first
win um sir roger bob that's your first
win as well
and uh the others i think you've won a
couple i think visual has the record for
the most
wins which is pretty sweet um
so guys as usual we're going to just go
through
a couple honorable mentions here so
steve we're
usually we just what i do is
it's tough to pick the winners because
there's so many good ones these days
and i want to encourage people
to you know if you don't win don't worry
the whole point is to learn
but it's a nice little added bonus just
to show you guys this stuff here
on the stream and give you like a line
or two
about what we like about it so how about
we do that i'll i'll put up a little
image on the screen here i'll say one
thing i love about it you say one thing
you love about it and then we'll move on
to the next one we got
about 20 to get through you sound good
uh
my stream is like five to ten seconds
behind yours
so okay that might be tricky
we'll do our best all right so the first
one here
is mr ronin with this one uh it's the
boxing one
looks super cool i love your textures i
love your color i love the gloss and the
reflectivity
on the ropes as well as this guy's body
and the negative space up top is like a
very like
it feels very heavy very hot and very uh
like like the stakes are very high it's
a big big production went into uh
into this boxing match i don't know that
that's the vibe i get from this one
yeah the the reflections are awesome uh
crazy detailed uh i'm really curious
about
whatever overlay is happening with like
the grid the pixel grid
i don't know what that is but it's super
rad yeah agreed
all right we got uh next up we got leaf
archer with this one
very cool wide open planes kind of vibe
here
got a tree way out in the distance a
big stretch of land lots of negative
space here it's a very simple
um simple framing simple setup that i
like a lot it kind of reminds me of
no country for old men in the beginning
when he goes out to that tree
yeah the atmosphere is awesome is that a
tumbleweed in the middle maybe
if it is um that's really cool
uh looks really good uh i like the horse
horses are awesome uh
yeah i yeah the atmosphere i love the
gradient of the sky
especially that really stands out to me
yeah good stuff
uh kimmy kimmy yo
i just love the composition on this one
simple black and white
very nice lighting good atmosphere got
some fog going
i really dig it yeah lots of good stuff
there
yeah the i mean i'm just immediately
drawn
like my eyes straight to the person uh
the lines the contrast
so on point yeah very nice it's really
well done
um rebane thank you for the super chat i
appreciate you
awesome horse awesome horse indeed all
right
uh we got joe the designer
i think is the name the way you
pronounce that i love it
very good uh nice use of color good use
of negative space up in the sky there
you got a character looking up at the
airplane um
good render quality i dig it
yeah not very often um you see renders
from that perspective
so nice job getting really creative with
it that's a cool idea
absolutely golden glitch is next
so this is classic negative space right
here
um i wanted to bring this one up and
show you guys i really like your
infrastructure
and your blocking of of objects here
i don't know what program you did this
in i don't know if this is like
ms paint or photoshop or what but like
classic negative space right here i
think this is cool
yeah i'd love to know like you're saying
like the workflow
for this because it's so unlike
everything else but it's awesome
yeah um i don't know about everyone else
but my eye is just drawn to
the top right corner that house and like
whenever i look at the image i
don't look anywhere else so just like
the openness and
man the color is so cool yeah i love the
gradient it's very nice job
like kind of water colory yeah um
folio is next this one's very cool
we got a train cut and through uh on
frame
right going to frame left which by the
way i read
anytime you have a character or
something going from frame right to left
because in english we read from left to
right
if a character is going from right to
left it feels like they're
returning or going back to where they
came from
and then if you're going from left to
right
then you're moving forward um
huh yeah like that cinematic language i
love it
it's the best
yeah the uh lighting is super cool like
i love how it's
illuminated inside and that's uh
lighting the landscape around it
um snow is probably a bit too big
but i love this makes me feel kind of
like cold
and the contrasting color between the
grayish blue and the
uh interior light is really nice nice
job
yeah uh next up we got burn scopes
alley i think that's the full name uh
this one's cool
this one's really cool i love it's very
simple
very very simple tons of negative space
um this could totally be
in some photo gallery somewhere but the
background there's like some
uh it looks like some sort of city some
buildings or some smoke stacks i can't
really tell
um but i think this one's very nice good
composition
yeah if you told me this was a black and
white photo
from like the 1920s or something
i'd totally believe it yeah um yeah this
is just
super cool vibe uh i could see this on
my wall
actually like on canvas yeah yeah
seriously
seriously it's very cool uh so congrats
on that one we got baron
is next with the penguins i love me some
penguins
um i thought this was like a fun little
negative space thing where you just cut
them out and put a background in
it's very fun and it's very playful and
i thought it was cool
yeah i'd also be curious about the
workflow on this one as well
um it's such a cool like commercial art
style
yeah i'm such a sucker for this yeah
agreed
agreed um next up is
our arcadia
arcadia this one's pretty dark but it's
it's really cool you have the one
central point of light um
going to the chair here now there's not
much
really going on in terms of negative
space like there is
the focus is the tv and the chair but
everything else kind of falls off into
darkness that you're not really seeing
um but it feels like it rides the line
and and i just thought it was a nice
render i thought it was pretty cool
yeah there's like just enough
illumination
to show that the artist knows exactly
what they're doing and like
how to compose a scene and control
exposure
uh but i agree it would be nice to see a
little bit more but i love that
the amount of detail you're implying is
awesome yeah like pristine yeah i love
the grunge
same is that i'm wondering if that's uh
mega scans you used
because i feel like i recognize that
wood grain
that's awesome um
anto is next this one is creepy man this
reminds me of like an old lithograph
or something some old creepy charcoal
like i don't know what this place is but
i think it's amazing i
i want this to be a d and d scene
like i i want to know more about this
because i could imagine like some
big baddie at the end and like oh man
this
ah i love like there's so so little
going on in the frame
but my mind immediately just like fills
in the blanks and tries to like write a
story around it yeah that's a good one
really really good one um two
legs in one as buoy
i don't know anyway this one's cool love
the colors
love the composition um
[Music]
very cool you're an architecture guy
aren't you steve
sorry so you're an architecture guy
aren't you uh
i have worked with architects well you
you do a lot of like
um architectural visualization stuff
right in unreal
so for sure yep yep yeah so the uh
the attention to like uh you know seal
it or roof materials and
walls how those would reflect light
that's really awesome here
i again curious about the workflow like
if this is done and cinema 4d
with some weird awesome shaders and
materials
that's really cool but if you told me
this was hand painted i'd also totally
believe it yeah
yeah the gradients in this one are just
really nice i love the colors
yeah yeah um yeah there's a little bit
of banding on my end but
if anything it makes it better that's
funny
uh zeffix is next with this one classic
again classic negative space
uh your canvas is white and you're just
filling in the black like the whole
the negative uh the negative space and i
think it looks really cool
you know you got your foreground with
the the hiker
and the mountains and then the
background this kind of looks like a
record
i'm imagining this is a record but yeah
that's cool
yeah this is 100
an album cover if it's not
you're probably lying to me it's
a lot of care and detail went into this
and it shows
yeah super cool um yeah cgmd
um always puts out incredible work this
one's really really cool
i like it's like you have a spotlight on
these guys but it's in the shape of some
like looks like a police detective an
anime police detective or something
i think it's super cool
yeah this is there's a lot going on a
lot of detailed textures
reflection lighting all around really
well done
uh and there's a lot of implied story
yes
which is the next level you want the
story that's where it's at
uh we got willy next with this one
freaking
massive scene with a tiny little star on
the on the
uh right third
willy does really good work he works in
blender he's like 14 or 15 years old
it's crazy
wow um
just awesome yeah i mean it's it's
a realistic kind of rendering but um
everything is just so washed out with
detail but that's you know
yeah definitely that was for that
distance yeah that's
i i've just noticed how dusty my laptop
screen is
so thank you whoever made this image
like wow
the detail in the stars like that's just
your dust man
that's hilarious awesome awesome um
we're a little bit more than halfway
done here probably got another 10. we
got
siri c troopa with this one again
classic classic negative space
i love it freaking cool that's about
that's about all there is to say about
that one
yeah the movement is awesome the sense
of motion the
layout really well done agreed
um spaghetti nero
same deal classic negative space
but with a twist uh your composition is
great
and then you have a really cool
reflection on the bottom of screen man i
think
it's very imaginative very cool
yeah but just the shadows oh it's so
good
great use of um just contrast
all around seriously just love it slim
the beast same deal there's a lot of
really good black and white ones with
some good silhouettes
um and you put it in context of a
theater
congrats man very cool yeah
yeah is is it dust again or is there
like graffiti
or something hanging out there stuff
okay yeah
looks really good yeah i like the
lighting yeah uh soulnate
classic classic little scene here
getting pushed off hopefully
nope looks like no ropes and
no uh parachute so that's gonna be a
rough one
yep um yeah
love the motion i mean whenever i see a
still image like this and i
i feel like i can anticipate the motion
that's happening
in progress that's just really well done
nice use of the rocks too
agreed yeah agreed uh rollerbob
13. this one this one came close to
winning for me
i really liked it um very creepy
it has a really dark vibe to it the
whole
bottom like three quarters of the frame
is just
scary it reminds me of fallout 3
coming out from those freaking sewers
yeah i dig this one
yeah this is the same as that one with
the tv that was lighting up the room
there's just enough lighting to
indicate like all of this crazy detail
nice job on that yeah absolutely
yeah 128 days later definitely i get
that vibe
um oh yeah powerless classic negative
space
very cool love the subject matter
um i feel like the foot though you have
that white spot in the arch of the foot
i feel like you could lose it
i think you can just have it be
completely black but otherwise
really nice yeah
i like the uh how distinct they are and
just
uh the logo is really well placed
it feels like there's a lot of story
happening here yeah these are all
desktop backgrounds you guys are
putting out good stuff play raise is
next this is just a solid render i like
your lighting
um i like your uh the materials that you
used
i think it looks really good um it's
just for me it's just missing a subject
um but
it's it's very nicely framed in the
sense that you have that x
on the right side there i think that's
pretty sweet you got the lighting
you kind of faked the perfect time of
day shot where the lighting had to be
just right for you to get the perfect
picture
so i think that's that's a really nice
addition you added in cg there
yeah if you told me this was 100 photo i
would totally believe it is it
are most of these just like part photo
part
composite is there any sort of like
limitation there does it have to all be
cg no it's all cg yeah these guys are
like full cg
seriously i mean it i assumed this was
photo with like
some composition on top of it that's
like that's crazy good detail yeah
seriously
this is good seriously uh lewis yo
welcome to the first stream man
good to have you um shout outs to all
you guys if this is your first stream
thanks for joining me
we're about to wrap up here we probably
got like five more pictures five more
honorable mentions to get through
we'll uh announce the new weekly
challenge and then we'll call it
um but yeah thanks guys for joining me
um oren cloud is the next one here
cool silhouettes um
i guess there's the the negative space
is in like the light
coming from that back light there which
is pretty sweet um and there's a lot of
like
foreground probably some foreground
elements i wonder if this one would have
been better
as a horizontal uh framing
i wonder oh yeah that's a good point i'm
really curious about what's going on in
the middle hanging down
but i guess that's kind of the point
like the bloom though
it's it's a nice amount of being blown
out yeah i think it's cool
um this next one is by one aspiring
artist
and i like it a lot it has the fondo
vibes to it um if you guys don't know
just google fondo as fan
space h-o oh no um
i love it man i really like the negative
space you're filling in with the shadow
from the uh like the the fire
escape from the opposite building maybe
or the same building but i think it's
really cool
yeah usually when people light a scene
or cast shadows
most of the time those shadows tend to
be like uniform diffusion
so it's cool that we're getting like
different like
uh feathering on those shadows i like
that super sick um
three more noodle chon i love your
colors
man your colors are really good uh i
like your framing
a whole lot you're using your squares
and your rectangles to get some really
nice framing here
your textures are fantastic and your
lighting is spot on you got the
the sunlight going from like the bottom
left on the stairs up to the top right
and it's perfectly lit
perfectly framed yeah really nice
attention to detail
especially like the leaves on the street
don't think i didn't notice that the
little bit of grass peeking out
that's that's like world-class detail
right there yeah
super necessary to getting something
above you know above the rest standing
out i think it's
very necessary so congrats on that one
uh we got
near with this other one super cool love
the silhouette
um negative space up in the up in the
atmosphere and the clouds and stuff
uh really doing a good job with the
lighting there i feel like you just
could have
did a little bit more detail on the
bridge itself
um it just looks like a couple
rectangles
with some splines it'd be cool to get in
there on the bottom to have some like
escape hatches and
different levels on the bridge to build
it out a little bit more it might have
taken it to the next level but
i mean you're still an honorable mention
it's like it feels good to me
yeah i love the the way it like fades
into solid white in the background
that's that's a really cool
uh style but i totally agree if the
bridge had like more thickness and more
um more detail on that that might be
cool to see
agreed um and lastly natty
with this one here this one almost won
it came very close it's a perfect image
like dude your your shadow is perfectly
lined up
with the bridge so it looks like one
straight line
your shapes are incredible your
rendering quality is incredible
this is so good and this is
not a photo i don't believe that for one
second
it's so good it's incredible
so y'all um congratulations to all you
guys for
joining the challenge here um for
hanging out with us
it has been amazing it has been a long
stream what do we got
almost five hours man yeah
man seriously so the last thing we need
to do here is just decide
the next weekly challenge that's the
last thing we need to do so steve let's
do this together
um yeah man what should these guys work
on we've done
robot we've done black and white we've
done silhouette we've done negative
space we've done
sci-fi we've done star wars we've done
we've done so many different things what
do you think
these guys should work on this week
what's a fun challenge maybe maybe give
it like three options
and then we'll do a poll to pick
yeah so i mentioned earlier how every
time i see
an architecture visualization especially
with unreal
it's always eastern european minimal
black and white minimalist apartment i'd
love to see like a total twist on that
like uh something super ironic like an
ironic environment or like
uh like like a pristine you know
museum or something but there's just
like a little like
you know blood patch on the ground or
something like
something like that it's just like it
really tells a story through the way the
environment is built
um something like that might be fun how
would we
boil that down to a prompt right like
uh you could got my mind thinking about
something
like uh overgrown
maybe like if it's like overgrown
because then it could like
you could play with how something has
been taken over by nature perhaps
um
is that kind of where you're going or
yeah
um like uh somebody said in the chat
environmental storytelling is a good way
to put that as well um
[Music]
overgrown definitely like that and that
kind of ties into
what we just made as well um
is my video looks a little choppy your
video is fine
oh no oh no let me try to cut my camera
off
what happened hold on
weird um well i'll just keep uh
coming up with ideas what about
can you still hear me like i mean i'm
getting levels up in here i don't know
why my camera just exploded and it's
back maybe overheated or something
oh yeah overgrown is good um
okay something with like hot and cold
might be good and like implying heat and
temperature
through the use of color and composition
oh okay hot and cold is very cool i'm
just going to put that as an option
okay um
[Music]
so we have overgrown we have hot and
cold what is one more that we could
throw to these
guys and they'll all vote on it
i'd love to see
a modern
recreation of
your favorite memory or like
a scene from an old school video game
with your own
modern twist to it oh wow i don't know
what you would call that
and that's more of just like a
a whole nother thing but um because we
did low poly
we did oh sorry i guess that's the old
school style of it we did low poly we
did
video game i wonder like
modern we did we did steampunk which is
like
old school but with like the tech um
i got it i got it nostalgia someone just
said if you can
post an image that makes me nostalgic
for something
i've never seen ever experienced some
place i've never been
we did so we did sentimental
that's so yeah that's the thing
nostalgia would be very
along those lines um
dang what's another one remastered
nostalgia
what's another one that's like a feeling
um maybe in
indecision or like oh
um what about nervous
oh yeah what does it
visually look like nervousness okay in
an environment let's do it nervous
okay um i'm gonna throw this throw a
link out to you guys okay and i'm gonna
pin it
i want you guys to vote on what y'all
want okay um so let's do
let's create this poll uh
weekly challenge one of you guys also
mentioned
uh announcing the challenge on friday
because the new deadline is friday i cut
it back by a day
to give me a chance to go over all the
awesome submissions
so i think i'm gonna try
and and get the new weekly challenge to
you guys by
by friday as opposed to saturday on the
stream so you guys get an extra day to
do it
uh but let's share this url with you
guys
boom and can i pin this
yes all right so we have the link pinned
in the chat go there and vote
on the weekly challenge this week we
have three options
overgrown hot and cold and nervous
and we'll see man these are these are
good ones yeah
super cool um
and while you guys are doing that i do
want to show you
let's see i want to show y'all
the new instagram page where we're going
to be
housing all of these things
so there's a new instagram page it's
called create with clint
um what are we at 80 followers 233
followers right now
very cool um so get on it guys create
with clint i'm going to be posting
all of the awesome uh winners here
i'll probably be doing some stories
throughout the week too of some
honorable mentions
but we got all the submissions in here
for like the ramen challenge
and shout outs to all the moderators who
really helped
get this instagram going we did
spongebob back in the day and we're
gonna just be updating this
um a few times a week to really
display and show all of your guys's best
work to the community and just
you know we're gonna everyone's tagged
in here everyone's got their instagrams
shouted out so we want to just get as
much traffic
over to your guys's page as possible we
also include an art station if you want
to do in our station too
um and we're debating going back and
forth like do we want to post
each winner as its own image or do you
guys like them stacked like this
and i think right now we're thinking we
obviously started it this way but i
think we might switch it up too so
that every winner is an individual post
just so nothing gets really
hidden you know we want every everyone
to really shine here so
yeah we're just we want to make it as as
good as it can be for the community so
um yeah go follow it create with clint
and
uh and yeah start start doing these
challenges they're really fun
so let's see let's see these uh these
results here
let's give it the old refresh and see
what we got
oh all right y'all um
so it looks like the winner here
yeah the winner if i'm gonna switch over
two seconds for a few seconds
um this is when i lose my mind is that
the end of the stream i'm like what is
going on
uh overgrown is the winner by three
percent
very close to hot and cold that would
have been fun but we can always get it
next time
so the new weekly challenge is overgrown
i want you guys to use that prompt to
create a render
um that fits the prompt all right
uh if you guys are focusing
on like one specific item like if you're
if you're gonna
do an overgrown water bottle model the
water bottle please
um don't just download it if you're
gonna do a more general scene
it's okay to kit bash stuff you know
obviously we're using the pulling
materials from a bunch of different
places
um but the point is to just create as
much of this stuff as you can
don't just download stuff follow a
tutorial and call it your submission
that'll that'll get you kicked you don't
want that you
we just want to be able to to learn as
much as possible
push ourselves so we can get better at
our passions every single week
so yeah if you guys want to join the
link to the discord is in the
description just go to
the weekly challenge i'm going to type
it up right after i
call this stream here we've been going
for about five hours
uh yeah so
uh my brain is gone at this point i have
no more words
man this is fun this is just a good time
heck yeah dude
i'm i'm jealous you get to do this every
week with
people who are just having such a good
time
it's freaking cool man it's really cool
everyone has been
so supportive you guys have been
sticking with me
every single stream here so i just
really appreciate you guys and steve
thank you
so much for helping me and unreal for
the last
few months and for doing this stream
with me man
um we got to get another one maybe we'll
do a big master material breakdown or
something i don't know
oh man that'd be fun i'd i'd love to
join anytime
uh right now uh we're currently in the
process of moving to a new house
and i also have a newborn so yeah thank
you it's um
time is you know tricky absolutely
i would love to join anytime um we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out
yeah yeah i really appreciate you man
thank you so much uh
and guys keep creating keep doing cool
stuff i'll see you on the discord this
week
uh and until then peace out y'all
see you steve thanks man later
[Music]
ten ten
so
[Music]
you